GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
CALLED ORDER. GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE THE COOK NINETEEN
EMERGENCY IN TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING TO MEET HERE THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING A FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IT
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE WAITED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIRES
ALLOW. AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY- TODAY'S. NUMBER
IS. 877-226-8152 IN THE ACCESS
CODE. IS. TWO EIGHT EIGHT OH
THREE TWO TWO. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE INDOOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WILL BE
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION PRESSES OLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR THE
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN
QUEUE TO THE FOR THE MODERATOR
TO CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT
THAT TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTE
IT IN YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
YOUR DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR FEELINGS IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
LIGHT TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT
SO ALL. INTERESTED PARTIES MAY
BE HER. WE A TWELVE BILLS ON
TODAY AGENDA. HOWEVER FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN SB SIX TWENTY BY
SENATOR STERN. HAS BEEN PULLED
BY THE AUTHOR. SO THE BILL WILL
NOT BE HEARD TODAY. BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH THE AGENDA I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR ALAN FOR TAKING
ON THE ISSUE OF DIRECT TO
CONSUMER SHIPPING AND FOR
ALLOWING THE COMMITTEE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND TIME. TO
CONTINUE THE WORK ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. WELL THE BILL
WILL NOT BE HEARD TODAY I'M
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE THE
WORKING ON THIS PLAN. ALL THIS
IMPLANT PUTTING TOGETHER AN
INFORMAL HEARING BEFORE THE
BILL WAS HEARD DURING OUR TO
YOUR BILL HEARING IN JANUARY. I
IMPORTANT STAKEHOLDERS ON BOTH
SIDES TO USE THIS TIME TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR YEAH COMMITTEE
ON CRAFTING LANGUAGE THAT WILL
HOPEFULLY LESSONS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
BY THE OPPOSITION. AGAIN THANK
YOU SENATOR ALAN- FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THE
WITH THIS COMMITTEE. BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESENTATIONS ON THE REST
OF BILLS LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. DONNA HERE DOT HERE
NIELSEN NIELSEN HERE ALLEN
ARCHULETA- MARCH LETTER HERE
BAKER BAKER HERE GORGEOUS
PRESIDENT BORDERS HERE BRO.
GLAZER YEAH GLAZER HERE WEST SO
HERE WESO JOHN. KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ HERE MELENDEZ HERE
PORTANTINO YES PORTANTINO HERE
RUBIO. RUBIO HERE WILK. NUMBER
WE HAVE A QUORUM. JERRY NOTES
OF CORN HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED-
MEMBERS THE PLAN FOR TODAY IS
TO BEGIN WITH OUR CONSENT ITEMS
THEY'RE MOVING THROUGH THE
AGENDA FILE ORDER AS I
INDICATED EARLIER RIGHT AFTER
THE CONSECUTIVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN CENTER CABALLERO.
AFTER EACH A BILL IS PRESENTED
WILL PLACE THE BILL ON CALL
AFTER ALL THE BILLS HAVE BEEN
HEARD I WILL OPEN THE ROLE IN
EACH BILL ONCE AGAIN TO GIVE
MEMBERS TO ANOTHER COMMITTEES
THE OPPORTUNITY VOTE ON TODAY'S
BILLS. DUE TO TIME CONSTRAINTS
IN THE LAKE TO HEARINGS%
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATION
CLEANING PROTOCOLS I'M LIMITING
TESTIMONY TO EITHER SIDE BY TWO
MINUTES TOTAL ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE I WILL BE LIMITING THE
ME TOOS TO TEN MINUTES PER SIDE
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ARKANSAS
GALLAGHER THEREFORE BILLS ON
CONSENT FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
FOUR SIXTY EIGHT FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR S. B. EIGHT SIXTEEN
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE S. B. E.
NINETEEN FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX.
SB EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT COULD
HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALLER SOME OF THE- MOTION BY.
SENATOR WILK- MEMBERS. PLEASE A
REMINDER TO WAIT UNTIL YOUR
MIKE IS TURNED ON TO PLEASE
SPEAK DIRECTLY INTO THE BIKE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
REMEMBER THIS IS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DODD. HI DON HI
NIELSEN ALL RIGHT NIELSEN HI
ALAN. ARCHULETA HI. HI. BAKER
HI GORGEOUS. FOR HI BRADFORD.
GLAZER HI GLAZER AYE WEST. I
HUESO I. K. MELENDEZ MELENDEZ I
PUT IN HI PORTANTINO AYE HI
RUBIO WILK HI WELL THAT IS A
LOT OF VOTES WILL PUT THAT ON
CALL FIVE DEL- WE WERE BE
MOVING TO ITEM- NUMBER CELL SO
CALL. GOOD MORNING CHAIR DIED
IN COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB TWENTY
EIGHT THE RURAL BROADBAND AND
DIFFA REFORM ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO COMMITTEE STAFF IN
AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER WHICH STATED THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
SHOULD INVENTORY STATE PROBLEM
PROPERTY FOR POSSIBLE USE FOR
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE BASED
ON CRITERIA FROM THE CPUC. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION AND OTHER
AGENCIES THE ORDER FURTHER
STATES THAT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE WILL IDENTIFY AND
FACILITATE NEW BROADBAND
PROJECTS IN SUPPORT OF
PRECISION AGRICULTURE AND FOOD
SYSTEMS AND RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND WITH CALLAWAY YES TO
INVENTORY BROADBAND
CONNECTIVITY TO ALL OF THE
FAIRGROUNDS SB TWENTY EIGHT
TAKES A SIMILAR APPROACH
REQUIRING THE CPUC THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
CALTRANS THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND OTHER RELEVANT
STATE AGENCIES TO INVENTORY
STATE RESOURCES. THAT CAN BE
MADE ABOUT AVAILABLE FOR
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE AT
MINIMUM SPEED OF A HUNDRED
MEGABITS PER SECOND DOWNLOAD
SPEEDS SB TWENTY EIGHT TAKES A
BROAD VIEW OF STATE RESOURCES
TO INCLUDE REAL PROPERTY THAT
COULD BE USED TO SITE BROADBAND
EQUIPMENT RIGHT TO RAISE IT
COULD BE USED FOR ROUTING FIBER
AND EVEN WIRELESS SPECTRUM THAT
COULD BE USED FOR BANDWIDTH
CAPACITY. SB TWENTY EIGHT
PRECLUDES THE USE OF STATE
RESOURCES IF THE USE WOULD
CREATE A RISK TO PUBLIC SAFETY
SUCH. AS THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL. SB TWENTY PASSED THE
RESP AGE TO CREATE TEMPLATE
LICENSING AGREEMENT SO THAT THE
STATE CAN READILY CONTRIBUTE
THESE RESOURCES TO BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE. SB TWENTY EIGHT
BILLS ON THE ADMINISTRATION'S
STRATEGY TO CLOSE THE GAPS WITH
STATE RESOURCES CONTRIBUTING TO
DESPERATELY NEEDED BROADBAND
DEPLOYMENTS. THIS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IN RURAL
AREAS WHERE THE CITING OF
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
EQUIPMENT CAN BE A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF A PROJECT'S TOTAL
CAPITAL COSTS. ELEMENTS FOR THE
FIRST TIME A STATUTE CALLED THE
DIGITAL INFRASTRUCTURE VIDEO
COMPETITION ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
SIX OR GIVE CAP. WHICH PROVIDES
CABLE AND TELECOMMUNICATION
COMPANIES WITH THE STATE WIDE
TEN YEAR LONG FRANCHISE LICENSE
TO DEPLOY DIGITAL VIDEO
SERVICES. SINCE DAVID DIFFICULT
PASSED THE DIGITAL VIDEO PAID
BUSINESS ACCOMPLISHED COMPLETE
MARKET SATURATION MEANING PAY
TV SERVICES ARE AS UBIQUITOUS
AS ENERGY AND WATER UTILITIES
NEARLY A COMMODITY AND THEIR
SCALE. WHAT IS NOT CHANGED IS
THAT WHILE DIFFICULT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BRING COMPETITION
TO THE PAY TV MARKET MARKET IT
DID NOT. JUST A HANDFUL OF THE
TWENTY EIGHT DIFFICULT
LICENSEES ALSO PROVIDE HIGH
SPEED INTERNET SERVICES 296% OF
THE STATE. COMMUNITIES WITHOUT
REAL BROADBAND ARE BEING
ABANDONED ENTIRE COMMUNITIES
HAVE STRUGGLED TO ACCESS TO
HIGH SPEED BROADBAND IN ORDER
TO MAKE THEIR ESSENTIAL
PURCHASES ONLINE WHICH WAS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT DURING
THIS COVERED VIRUS. WORK FROM
HOME AS REQUIRED BY THE SHELTER
IN PLACE ORDER ACCESS VIDEO
COMMUNICATIONS LIKE ZOOM OR
ATTEND SCHOOL THROUGH ONLINE
EDUCATION PLATFORMS THE PICTURE
OF THE TWO YOUNG GIRLS FROM MY
DISTRICT USING THE INTERNET
CONNECTION IN FRONT OF TALK
ABOUT DURING THE PANDEMIC. IT'S
A HAUNTING PICTURED THAT DR
HOLE THAT DRIVES HOME THE
UNEXPECTED SEPT DOUBLE STATE OF
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE IN ALMOST
ALL CASES TE COMMUNITIES IN
THE STATE WITHOUT HIGH SPEED
INTERNET OR RURAL COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR AND ARE ULTIMATELY
UNSERVED OR UNDERSERVED BECAUSE
THEY'RE LOW INCOME. LOW
POPULATION LOW POPULATION
DENSITY OR BOTH. DIFFICULT
FRANCHISEES HAVE BEEN SUBJECTED
TO LOW INCOME BILL THAT
REQUIREMENTS CENTS TWENTY CENTS
TWENTY OH FIVE. AND THE CPUC
DOES NOT RECEIVE SUFFICIENT
SELF REPORTED DATA FROM THE
LICENSEES TO KNOW IF THOSE
RESIDENTS ARE RESERVING ARE
RECEIVING SERVICES. IN A NON
DISCRIMINATORY MANNER SB TWENTY
REFORM DIPPED REQUIRING GRAND
DATA BE REPORTED IT TO THE C.
P. U. C. SO THAT FINALLY THE
STATE WILL HAVE AN ACCURATE
ACCOUNTING OF THE GAPS. GAINING
THIS ACCURATE NETWORK MAP IT'S
CRITICAL FOR CALIFORNIA WITHOUT
THIS DATA THE CPUC CANNOT
READILY DETERMINE IF A LICENSE
SHOULD BE RENEWED FOR AN
ADDITIONAL TERM OF TEN YEARS.
AND RENEWING A STATEWIDE
LICENSE FOR THAT LENGTHY PERIOD
OF TIME WITHOUT THIS DATA IS
NOT IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST. SB
TWENTY EIGHT HAS A CLEAR INTENT
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WITHOUT ANY PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION. FROM
THE CONSUMER BEING SHARED- AND
IT'S FOR THAT REASON THAT I
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE MET
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS CLARIFYING
THAT NO PERSONAL INFORMATION-
WILL BE SHARED THE BILL
REQUIRES THE CPUC TO CONSULT
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITHIN
THE FRANCHISEE'S. SERVICE
TERRITORY REGARDING REMEDIES
FOR THE SERVICE IMPACTS. AS
PART OF ANY PROCEEDING TO
SUSPEND OR REVOKE THE FRANCHISE
AND IT IS THE STICK THAT
MATTERS MORE MORE. MOST BECAUSE
PRIOR TO DIFFICULT FRANCHISE
HOLDERS HAD TO NEGOTIATE WITH
EACH LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO GAIN
SUBSCRIBER ACCESS MANY OF YOU
WHO SERVED IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
REMEMBER THOSE DAYS WHEN THEY
THESE. FRANCHISEES HAD TO
NEGOTIATE WITH OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AROUND WHAT
SERVICES WOULD BE PROVIDED OF
WHAT WAS IN THE BASIC PACKAGE
AND HOW MUCH THEY'D BE CHARGING
FOR THAT. DIFFICULT REMOVED
LOCAL CITIES AND COUNTIES FROM
THE GO SHEETING TABLE AND SB
TWENTY EIGHT RESTORES LOCAL
EMPOWERMENT WITHOUT IMMEDIATELY
SHIFTING THE COST AND
COMPLEXITY OF NO NEGOTIATING
THE FRANCHISE AGREEMENTS. BACK
TO THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
TODAY IS JEFF MEAL FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. THANK YOU AND I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
SENATOR PROBABLY MORNING MISTER
NAY. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS- HE
SACKETS SUPPORT OF SB TWO EIGHT
BOTH THE THAT WOULD CREATE A
STATE IN THE OF THE COULD BE
HELPED IN TACKLING BROUGHT BY.
WHICH IS ONE OF THE RECOMMEND.
BROADBAND FOR ALL ACTION PLAN
WHICH EXECUTIVE DOORS IN HOLD
WHICH WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO A DOCTOR OF HAVE
BEEN ALSO PART RELATING TO
DISCUSS. AS KABIR MENTIONED
BEFORE DIFFERENT UNIQUE COME
HAD TO WITH COUNTY SAN CITY.
WHEN THEY TO START SERVING THE
THEY WANTED JUST A HIGH THE
COMMUTER THE CASHIER'S- COULD
WORK THEM TO SERVE THE LOW AREA
THE COMMUNITY AS WELL BUT IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX THE COMPANY'S
PUSHED HARD FOR THE BEST A
RANGE. THAT IS THAT IN MY
BECAUSE WITH THE COUNTY AND
CITIES THEY AND FOR US BRANCH I
PHARMACY THAT NEW TO A BIT
MODEL WOULD LEAD TO EVERY
GETTING TO SERVER THE FIRST
BETTER AND YOU. BOUTIQUES BORN
OF FIFTEEN UNDER THE MODEL WE
KNOW KNOW WHAT THE RESULTS OF
THIS EXPERIMENT TO DETER
CLEANING FROM HAVE SLOT TO THE
SERVICE AND HIGH PROFIT MARKETS
BUT LOW PROFIT THERE IS.
COMMUNITY IMPROVE. HAVE BEEN
LEFT BEHIND. BUT FOUGHT SO HARD
TO HAVE BEEN FOUR MINUTES. IT'S
HARD TO IMAGINE PG&E FOR
EXAMPLE REFUSING TO TELL THE
STATE WHICH HOMES AND
BUSINESSES THEY SERVE. AS HARD
TO IMAGINE A PRIVATE WATER
COMPANY REFUSING TO SAY NOT
ONLY WHICH RESIDENTS A SERVICE
BUT ALSO WHETHER THE WATER MEET
STATE AND FEDERAL REGULATION.
FOR BROADBAND WHICH WE ALL KNOW
AGREED AS A UTILITY. NECESSARY
FOR MODERN LIFE. BUT HE'S OUR-
THAT HELD THE STATE WHETHER THE
RED. OF RURAL COMMUNITIES AND
DISADVANTAGED HAVE BROADBAND
ACCESS AND WHETHER IT MEETS THE
WEATHER THE SPEECH STATE AND
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS. BUT THIS
IS. HOW KIDS GO TO SCHOOL THE
STATUS OF HOW PEOPLE SIGNED UP
FOR BANKS DIDN'T ACCESS MEDICAL
CARE. TO THE SOLUTION SB TWENTY
TO SIMPLE IT JUST SAYS THIS
INITIALLY BUT THE CAN YOU SEE
CAN DO ALL THE THINGS THAT
COUNTIES AND CITIES USED TO BE
ABLE TO DO. A WHEN WE HAD LOCAL
FRANCHISES IN THE DIGITAL
SERVICE PROVIDER ISN'T MEETING
ITS RESPONSIBILITIES. TO GO
ALONG WITH THE BENEFITS IT GETS
FROM DITKA. COUNTIES AND CITIES
CAN RETURN TO THEIR SEAT AT THE
TABLE AND MAKE SURE THAT
COMMUNITIES HAVE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO THE. SERVICES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- NOW LET'S BE
WITH ANY OTHER WHICH- AND
GALLERY. C. NONE LET'S MOVE TO
ROOM ONE TWO. SEEING THAT AS
WELL THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB.
TWENTY THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO. SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE S. B. TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
AND FIRST WE HAVE NINE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FINE FORTY
HERE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CARE OFTEN BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF LOS BANOS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE
MINE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE HILLARY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LUCY SALCEDO
CARTER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT NINE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOINT STERLING
CHAIR OF THE ROLE CAUCUS IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DANIEL GUTIERREZ
ON BEHALF OF TURN THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK IN SUPPORT. AND
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF. BILL PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN. ZERO NINE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT IS ALL.
THANK YOU MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WE
WILL NOW FALL THE SAME PROCESS
IN HERE FOR MANY OPPOSITION ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY SEEING NONE SEEING- NO
BODY IN ROOM ONE TWELVE THE
WISHES TO TESTIFY WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
ARVEST MODERATOR IF YOU'D
PLEASE PROPPED INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWENTY.
GERMAN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THE B. TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
NOW. IN ONE MOMENT. AND AGAIN
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. FIRST WE
HAVE NINE FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS AT CAROLYN MCINTYRE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CABLE AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION. RESHAPE THE OSCARS
GOAL OF ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
HIGH SPEED INTERNET SERVICE BUT
WE MATCH RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB
TWENTY EIGHT AND THEN UNLAWFUL
EXPANSION OF THE STATE VIDEO
FRANCHISING AUTHORITY THAT IS
NOT TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL AND
WOULD ACTUALLY DETER INVESTMENT
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS
IS A LIVE STATE FORTY TWO ISSUE
CABLE AND VIDEO FRANCHISES IS
DERIVED FROM FEDERAL LAW TITLE
SIX IN THE COMMUNICATIONS ACT
THIS LAW EXPRESSLY PROHIBITS
FRANCHISING AUTHORITIES
BLIGHTED SI PC FROM REGULATING
BROADBAND INTERNET ACCESS
SERVICE PROVIDED BY CABLE
OPERATORS EXCEPT IN LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT NOT INCLUDE.
BROADBAND AVAILABILITY
REQUIREMENTS LIKE THOSE.
DISCUSSED IN SB TWENTY EIGHT.
NOTHING IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
GRANTS THE STATE AUTHORITY TO
USE STATE FRANCHISING TO
REGULATE BROADBAND SERVICE
CLEARLY STATED THE STATE IS
PREEMPTED BY FEDERAL LAW. THE
BILL WOULD ALSO CREATE
UNCERTAINTY AND POTENTIAL
DISRUPTION FOR EXISTING SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND THEIR CUSTOMERS
WHICH ULTIMATELY WOULD GET HER
NOT ADVANCE BROADBAND
DEPLOYMENT. BOARD SPECIFICALLY
SB TWENTY EIGHT WOULD REQUIRE
EACH DIFFERENT FRANCHISEE TO
DEPLOY INFRASTRUCTURE CAPABLE
OF PROVIDING SERVICE AT THE
HOUSEHOLD LEVEL TO ALL
HOUSEHOLDS IN A SENSE OF SPOT.
SENATORS BLOCKED ROADS
CONFLICTS WITH HOW DIFFERENT
SERVICE AREAS ARE REPRESENTED
TO THE CPC SHAPE FILES OF
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS THAT DO NOT
ALIGN. WITH DENTISTS BUT DOWN
THREE. DO AND SEVENTY COMES THE
TO HAVING MAY NOW PROVIDE IN A
PART OF THE SENSE OF A LOT WITH
THEIR GIVE COMPLAIN AREA. THERE
ARE CASES WHERE DEPLOY AFTER.
TWENTY FAIR. HAVE BEEN A HOLD
FOR MONTHS OR YOU DID TODAY IN
THAT PERMITS. IN EVERY CASE IS
THE CELANESE MAKE PASS THROUGH
A SENSE BLOCK IN ORDER TO
RETAIN ENTERPRISE CUSTOMER IN
ANOTHER AREA AND ARE NOT
ENGINEERED TO PROVIDE READ
RESIDENTIAL SERVICE. TWENTY
EIGHT IS ALSO NOT TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL. THERE ARE A VARIETY
AND AB VIDEO STREAMING SERVICES
AS WELL AS WIRELESS
TECHNOLOGIES THAT OPERATE
WITHOUT A DIFFERENT FRANCHISE.
SB TWENTY EIGHT WOULD IMPOSE
NEW MANDATE ONLY ON DIFFERENT
FRANCHISEE. ESTABLISHING
DIFFERENTIAL REGULATORY
TREATMENT AMONG COMPETING
PROVIDERS BETTER THAN FAIR AND
WOULD ACT AS AN IMPEDIMENT TO
MARKET FORCES THAT HAVE
GENERATED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN BROADBAND. NETWORK
INVESTMENT IN RECENT YEARS- I
RECKON THAT THE SENATOR DID IN
FACT AGREE TO ACCEPT AMENDMENTS
TO ADDRESS PRIVACY ISSUES THAT
MAY ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS AT THE STATE LEVEL BUT
THERE ARE ALSO SIGNIFICANT
PRICES PRIVACY. REQUIREMENTS
AND RESTRICTIONS IMPOSED BY THE
FEDERAL CABLE ACT THAT WE
BELIEVE WOULD ALSO BE VIOLATED
BY THE SPELL FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AT THREE
TWENTY EIGHT ADD ON LEVEL AND
REQUEST THAT NO MATTER. THANK
YOU. MODERATE COMING HERE NEXT.
ADELINE. THIRTY SEVEN. MODERATE
COULD YOU ASK AGAIN PLEASE.
ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN. ZERO CAN ONE MOMENT. AND
FROM NINE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT WITH THE CHAIR- THIS
IS A LAW THAT THAT INCIDENT
WITH CAL COM- IN OPPOSITION TO
S. B. TWENTY EIGHT- AND DELETE
THE COMMENTS FROM- CAROLYN
MCINTYRE WITH CABLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO. SPEAKING
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN. ZERO AMAZON THANK YOU
MODERATOR IN THANK YOU TO OUR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL HELP BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK THE MEMBERS DELIVER
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE AT CENTER
HUESO LOSE THE BILL. CENTER
CABALLERO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- ATTENTION AS
SOMEONE ALSO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THIS UP- EARLY IN IN THE
HEARING- THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT THE CPUC HAS THE
AUTHORITY. TO TO LOOK AT AND TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR THE
FRANCHISEES ARE- THE DIFFICULT
FRANCHISEES ARE ACTUALLY
MEETING THE REQUIREMENTS THAT
THEY AGREED TO. FIFTEEN YEARS
AGO THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE KNOW
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED DURING
THIS PANDEMIC THAT THEY'RE NOT.
WE HAVE A HUGE AREAS WHERE
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO SERVICE
OR THE SERVICE IS SO SLOW DIED
ON OUR- STUDENTS DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO GET ON IS IN CLASS.
AND AND IT MISSED A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT- THIS IS A REASONABLE
APPROACH IT GIVES THE CPUC YOU
KNOW QUITE FRANKLY MY ORIGINAL
CONCEPT WAS TO BLOW UP THAT
THE- STATEWIDE FRANCHISE
AGREEMENT TO GO BACK TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND- AND HAVE THEM
PARTICIPATE IN A DISCUSSION
ABOUT HOW THEY'RE GOING TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE- COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. THAT DESPERATELY NEED
ACCESS- BUT THIS THIS I WAS YOU
KNOW- CONVINCED TO GET OFF OFF
THE CLIFF AND TAKE A MUCH MORE
REASONABLE APPROACH THIS GIVES
THE CPUC THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO
ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT. WHO IS
GETTING THE SERVICE- BYE BYE
AREA AND LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN
USE THE ACCESS FUNDS THAT WE
HAVE- THAT WE COLLECT IN ORDER
TO PROVIDE. IT INFRASTRUCTURE
TO BE ABLE TO DO IT IN A
COORDINATED WAY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU SENATOR AND SO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR HUESO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVEN SB
TWENTY EIGHT DOT BY DOT HI
NIELSEN ALL RIGHT NIELSEN HI
ALLEN. HI ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA
AYE ARCHULETA AYE BAKER. BAKER
HI GORGEOUS. GORGEOUS HI
BRADFORD GLAZER. AYE GLAZER AYE
WESSEL. AYE HUESO HAI JONES.
KAMLAGER MELENDEZ. PORTANTINO
RIGHT PORTANTINO HI RUBIO HI
RUBIO AYE WILK. THE BILL HAS
TEN VOTES WILL PLACE A BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU
CENTER. I WILL NOT HEAR THE
PRESIDING DUTIES TO OUR VICE
CHAIR SENATOR NIELSEN- HE WILL
NOW PROVIDE INSIGHT- TAKE UP MY
BILLS. WE GET IS MIKE ON PLEASE.
PARDON THERE YOU GO. I DON'T
ONE THAT'S YOUR FIRST ONE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
ALL THE AMENDMENTS LISTED ON
THE ANALYSIS AS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS OKAY. BUT OBJECTION
IT WILL BE ADOPTED. AS ALL OF
YOU ARE AWARE OF EARLY LAST
YEAR THE DEPARTMENT OF ABC
PROVIDING REGULATORY RELIEF FOR
ALCOHOLIC LICENSE- BY ALLOWING
RESTAURANTS THE ABILITY TO SELL
BOTH PRE PACKAGED ALCOHOL
DRINKS IN PRE MIXED DRINKS TO
CUSTOMERS AS PART OF ITS TO GO
MEAL ORDER. SB THREE EIGHTY
NINE BUILD UPON THAT REGULATORY
BILL RELIEF BY ALLOWING A
HOLDER OF AN ON SALE RETAIL
LICENSE WHICH INCLUDES
RESTAURANTS AND BARS. THE
ABILITY TO SELL BOTH PRE
PACKAGED ALCOHOLIC DRINKS IT
PRE MIXED DRINKS FOR
CONSUMPTION OFF THE LICENSED
PREMISES. UNLIKE THE REGULATORY
RELIEF. THIS BILL DOES NOT
REQUIRE THE PURCHASE OF A DRINK
TO BE ACCOMPANIED BY A MEAL
THIS IS BECAUSE THE REGULATORY
RELIEF. THIS THE BECAUSE UNDER
THE REGULATORY RELIEF THIS IS A
SIMPLY DONE TO DISTINGUISH
BETWEEN A RESTAURANT IN A BAR.
THE MEAL REQUIREMENT ALSO HAS
PROVED TO BE DIFFICULT TO
ENFORCE ANSWERS NO CLEAR
GUIDANCE ON WHAT ENCOMPASSES A
MEAL. HOWEVER THIS BILL
INCLUDES A NUMBER OF SAFEGUARDS
THAT WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
REGULATORY RELIEF. FOR EXAMPLE
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
CONTAINER BE SEALED IN A MANNER
THAT IS DESIGNED TO PREVENT
CONSUMPTION WITHOUT THE
BREAKING OF THE SEAL.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY WOULD
ALSO REQUIRE CONTAINERS TO BE
CLEARLY LABELED OR OTHERWISE
IDENTIFIED AS CONTAINING
ALCOHOL. BOTH THESE NUMBERS ARE
DESIGNED TO HELP LAW
ENFORCEMENT CLEARLY IDENTIFY.
THESE CONTAINERS INTO EASILY
DETERMINE IF THE INDIVIDUAL HAS
BROKEN THE SEAL AND CONSUMED
ANY OF THE ALCOHOL. IN ADDITION
THE MY OFFICE IS WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
ABC TO INCLUDE ADDITIONAL
SAFEGUARDS FOR EXAMPLE MY STAFF
IS WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
TO ADD. LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
THAT WOULD FURTHER PROTECT
AGAINST THE DELIVERY OF ALCOHOL
TO ANYONE UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE. EXCUSE ME. I WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR. IT THAT
NOTHING IN THIS BILL CHANGES
ANY LAWS RELATED TO DRINKING
AND DRIVING OR DRINKING IN
PUBLIC THERE'S ALSO NOTHING IN
THE BILL THAT FORCES ANY
LICENSEE TO ACTUALLY DO THIS
THIS BILL SIMPLY PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
BUSINESSES THAT WERE RAVAGED BY
COVERT NINETEEN. AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR BUSINESSES THAT DID THEIR
PART IN STOPPING THE SPREAD OF
THE STATE'S DEADLY VIRUS EVEN
IF IT MEANT SACRIFICING THEIR
LIVELIHOOD I BELIEVE THIS BILL
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO REPAY SOME OF THAT SACRIFICE
YEAH I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE TODAY HERE WITH ME IS
MATT SUTTON WITH A CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION AND
DAVID HOUSTON OWNER OF.
BARNEY'S DEANERY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE WILL THEN PROCEED
TO YOUR SUPPORT WITNESSES WE
HAVE MISTER SUTTON. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MET CERTAIN
OF THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION YOU CONSIDER LOTS
OF BILLS LOTS OF GOOD BILLS
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN PRACTICE
BEFORE WHAT YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU
TODAY IS A BILL THAT HAS BEEN
IN PLACE THE POLICY. THE
UNDERLYING POLICIES BEEN IN
PLACE FOR OVER A YEAR DUE TO
THE ABC RELAXATION OF
REGULATIONS ON THIS TOPIC AND
JUST TO PUT IT IN CONTEXT AT
THE OUTSET OF THE PANDEMIC THE
FIRST ENTITIES TO BE CLOSED FOR
ALL ON SITE DINING RESTAURANTS
AND SO TAKE OUT AND DELIVERY
WERE THE ONLY OPTIONS FOR
RESTAURANTS. THAT ACTUALLY
CONTINUED THROUGH MOST OF LAST
YEAR WE HAD AN ON AGAIN OFF
AGAIN- ABILITY TO DINE ON SITE-
BUT LARGELY WE WERE ENCOURAGED
IF NOT FORCED TO DO OFFSITE
DINING. AND THE STATE PROTOCOLS
FIFTEEN PAGES RESTAURANT OVER
NINETEEN PROTOCOLS THAT ARE
STILL IN PLACE TODAY PLACE A
HIGH EMPHASIS ON DELIVERY AND
TAKEOUT SO. SB THREE EIGHTY
NINE HELPS ALIGN WITH THAT TO
CHANGE RESTAURANT LANDSCAPE-
CURRENTLY THAT STILL EXISTS
TODAY WITH THOSE RESTRICTIONS
ON CAPACITY AND IT LOOKS
FORWARD BECAUSE WHAT'S HAPPENED
IS AS WE'VE ALL DONE SOME
PANDEMIC PIVOTING YOU PROBABLY
NOTICED A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS IN RESTAURANTS WITH. PRE
ORDERING VIA TECHNOLOGY-
ORDERING WITH A Q. R. CODE NO
PHYSICAL MENUS IN MANY
RESTAURANTS SOME RESTAURANTS
YOU CAN ORDER YOUR FOOD AHEAD
OF TIME SO THAT IT'S PREPARED
WHEN YOU ARRIVE THERE'S SO MANY
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT HAVE
CHANGED IN THE RESTAURANT
LANDSCAPE AND ONE THING IS
CONSUMER EXPECTATIONS IS
CHANGED AS WELL. AND SO GOING
FORWARD CONSUMERS HAVE A HIGHER
RELIANCE ON ENJOYING THAT
RESTAURANT EXPERIENCE OFFSITE
AT THEIR HOME OR OTHER
LOCATIONS SB THREE EIGHTY NINE
THE SENATOR DODD POINTED OUT
COMES WITH A NUMBER OF PUBLIC
SAFETY PROTECTIONS. THAT MAKE
US HANDLE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
JUST THE WAY WE DO IN A
RESTAURANT WITH EVEN MORE
PROTECTIONS FOR THEM TO BE
TAKEN OFF SITE. SO WE THINK
THIS STRIKES A GREAT BALANCE I
DEFINITE PROTECTS. SAY AND IT
ALIGNS WITH THE FUTURE OF THE
CHANGE RESTAURANT LANDSCAPE AND
WE THANK YOU AND WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU
MISTER SUTTON DO WE HAVE MISTER
HOUSTON AVAILABLE. YES I'M HERE
THANK YOU- MY NAME IS DAVID
HOUSTON AND THE OWNER OF A BAR
IS BEING RE- GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER MEMBERS I'M
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE EIGHTY
NINE I DON'T KNOW THANK A
SENATOR DODD FOR HIS- TOUGHER
APPROACH ON THIS ISSUE- I DON'T
TO TELL YOU. THAT THIS LAST
YEAR HAS BEEN EXTREMELY ROUGH-
IN THE RESTAURANT BUSINESS.
OUTSIDE OF PANDEMIC WE WERE
ORDERED CLOSED. AND WE ARE
ORDER TO EMPHASIZE. THE
CURBSIDE PICK UP AND- TAKE
AWAY. ONE OF THE GOOD THINGS
THAT CAME OUT OF THIS WAS OF
THE ABILITY TO SELL BEVERAGES
WITHOUT A LOT OF CUSTOMERS.
THAT FREQUENT RESTAURANT.
CALLED REGULARS I GUESS THEY
HAVE A MEAL THAT THEY LIKE AND
THEY HAVE A BEVERAGE THAT THEY
LIKE TO GET WITH THAT SO. FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO ORDER THE
YOU KNOW THE STONE IPA ALONG
WITH THEIR BURGER TO. BE
SPECIFIC IT MORE COMPLETES THAT
RESTAURANT EXPERIENCE THAT THEY
WERE LACKING AND ENCOURAGES
THEM. TO CONTINUE ORDERING AND
THAT'S THAT. REVENUE SOURCE
THAT WE DESPERATELY NEEDED IN
THIS DIFFICULT TIME- SB THREE
NINE TAKES WHAT'S IN PLACE FOR
IT IN IN PLACE PER YEAR AND
JUST SEEKS TO MAKE IT OUT LAST
THE PANDEMIC WHICH I THINK IS A
GOOD IDEA. AND IT GIVES JUST
THAT LITTLE BIT OF HELP TO
RESTAURANTS THAT ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE STRUGGLING. REALLY
OVER THE NEXT. THE ONLY KNOWS
HOW LONG IT'S GOING TO BE BUT
IT'S A VERY TOUGH DIFFICULT
CLIMB BACK IN. TO WHERE WE ONCE
WERE JUST A YEAR AND A HALF AGO
SO. EVERY LITTLE BIT HELPS AND-
THIS WOULD BE ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT HELP- I WOULD ASK
YOU TO SUPPORT THREE NINE TODAY
IT IT MODERNIZE ALCOHOL SERVICE
IN RESTAURANTS AND ACKNOWLEDGES
EIGHT. PERMANENTLY CHANGE
RESTAURANT LANDSCAPE. IT
REQUIRES TIGHT CONTROLS AND
MOVES POLICY BOARD THAT IS
PROOF HAS PROVEN TRACK RECORD
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU THIS IS CERTAIN AND- WILL
LOOK UP IN THE GALLERY I DID
ANYMORE INDIVIDUALS HERE
PRESENT THAT WISH TO TESTIFY
FROM THE GALLERY. J. NONE LETS
GO TO ROOM. ONE TWELVE. SEEING
NO ONE IN THE ROOM WILL WONDER
TWELVE. THEN WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A PROMPT IN THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
SUPPORT- TO BE IN OPPOSITION
OKAY. DO WE HAVE ANYONE CLEARLY
AND GERMAN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
ONE MOMENT.
WE HAVE LINE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING BALLERINA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT SB EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN Q. THEY'RE
GETTING THEIR NINE NUMBER ONE
MOMENT CONNECTED A LINE OF
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION. WE'LL
GET TO MOMENTARILY ANY FURTHER
PEOPLE AND SUPPORT IN Q. YES
NEXUS LINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS- TIM SCHMELZER
REPRESENTING WINE INSTITUTE-
WANTED TO THANK SENATOR DODD
FOR ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS-
RELATIVE TO THE- SINGLE SERVE
CONTAINER OF WINE AND- WANTED
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT WE SUPPORT
THE MEASURE. THANK YOU. VERY
GOOD. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK WITH AN- SPEAKING
ON SB THREE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO AND THEN
THE PHONE. WE WILL PROCEED AND
TO THOSE OF THE OPPOSITION. AND
I'VE SEEN UNDER THE GALLERY TO
HAVE ANY AND ONE TWELVE. IN
OPPOSITION IT. SEEING NONE THE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PUT IN KILL
ANYONE WHO WOULD TESTIFY VIA.
REMOTE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THE
L. THREE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
LINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHARE MEMBERS FRED JONES ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE PAGE
ORGANIZATION CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
ALCOHOL PROBLEMS WE SUBMITTED
OUR OPPOSITION LETTER WEDNESDAY
LAST WEEK. I THINK WE MISSED
THE DEADLINE TO BE INCLUDED IN
THE BILL ANALYSIS BUT WE DID
SENATE OPPOSITION- WE RECOGNIZE
THAT KOHLI HAMMERED THE
RESTAURANT AND BAR INDUSTRY
DISPROPORTIONATELY MORE THAN
ANY OTHER SECTOR- BUT WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT SHOULD BE A PRETAX
FOR PROVIDING A PERMANENT. NEW.
MEANS OF DISTRIBUTING ALCOHOL.
A RESTAURANT THE BARS. ABC HAS
HAD A- IN ENFORCING THESE
DELIVERIES. AND THEY HAVE HAD
HUGE CONCERNS AND PROBLEMS
THEIR OWN DATA- WITH THE
INAPPROPRIATE US. PROVIDING
ALCOHOL TO USE THAT HOMES AND
OTHER ISSUES AND CONCERNS WITH
THE RESTAURANTS AND BARS
THEMSELVES- DELIVERING THESE
PRODUCTS WE BELIEVE A THIRD
PARTY DELIVERY SYSTEM IS
PROBABLY MORE RESPONSIBLE- SO
YOU DON'T HAVE- RESTAURANTS IN
THERE BUSBOYS OUT. WITH
COCKTAILS TO GO SHOW FOR THOSE
REASONS AND OTHERS WE HAVE TO
OPPOSE THE CHAIRS THANK. UP
NEXT WE HAVE FIND THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MICHAEL SKIP ON BEHALF OF
ALCOHOL JUSTICE. NO ONE CAN
DENY THE IMPORTANCE OF ALCOHOL
SALES TO RESTAURANTS BOTTOM
LINE ESPECIALLY DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. BUT COCKTAILS TO GO
ARE A BAD IDEA TO THE STATE
BOTTOM LINE- EVERSPIN- THERE
HAS BEEN EVIDENCE LINKING THE
DEATH AND INJURY FROM DRINKING
AND DRIVING- THERE HAS BEEN A
PROHIBITION ON COCKTAILS TO GO-
WE BELIEVE THAT IT IS NOT IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY TO MAKE THIS
A PERMANENT PRIVILEGE. FORTY
TWO THE CDC CALIFORNIA ALREADY
SUFFERS MORE ANNUAL ALCOHOL
RELATED HARM THAN ANY OTHER
STATE OVER TEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED ALCOHOL RELATED DEATHS.
THIRTY FIVE BILLION IN TOTAL
COSTS FOURTEEN POINT FIVE
BILLION IN STATE COSTS. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU STOP
THIS BILL IN YOUR COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR THE
OPERATOR ANYTHING. TOMORROW
NEVER MIND THIRTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MY
RECOMMENDED THAT I AM A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL POLICY
ALLIANCE REPRESENTING OVER
FIFTY AGENCIES ASSOCIATIONS AND
GROUPS ACROSS THE STATE
REPRESENTING OUR CONCERN FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY WE ARE
TOLD SB THREE EIGHTY NINE WE
CANNOT. ABC WILL IMPORT ANY
UPDATES AS WE HAVE HEARD THERE
ARE A LOT OF CONCERN- DAY IT IS
NOT POSSIBLE- TO ACTUALLY PROVE
THAT THIS DEAL IS GOING TO BE
INSURED THERE IS ALSO A CONCERN
FOR CRIMINALIZATION AND
HELPFUL- AND DRINKING AND
DRIVING I'M BILLS THAT ARE
ALREADY HEAVILY POLICED
COMMUNITIES BROWN AND BLACK
FOLKS- NOW WILL BE FURTHER
COMPROMISE. THAT- ALREADY WE
HAVE HI- OF THE WHOLE CARE.
DURING THE- OUR COMMUNITY BEST
TO FROM COLEMAN. I DON'T
INCREASE ABOUT ACTED POINT
QUICKLY CAUGHT UP THE BALL. IN
THE HUGE. FOR LINE NUMBERS AND
HERE HERE THAT. IS ARE
SUFFERING THERE ARE STRUGGLING
PARKING. AND COVER COMING BUT-
WE COLOR ELEVATING THE L. G. B.
COMMUNITY DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT BY. ACCESS IS DRUG AND
BY THEN BUSINESS- WE AREN'T
CONVERT PEOPLE OF LIFE OF OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WILL BE WITH.
ASK FOR THE BILL THE V- TAKING
AWAY. REGISTRATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU BEST PLAN
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THERE MY NAME IS PAT HOLY AND I
CORD THE AND DRUG PREVENTION IN
CANADA ON THE BALLOT THE COLOR
OF MEMBERS- AND WE ARE AND OF
CAL HOPEFUL ALLIANCE. I JUST
WANT TO GO ON THE RECORD AS
SAYING IT IS WELL KNOWN BY THE
HOUSTON MY COMMUNITY THAT THEY
CAN ALREADY GET ALCOHOL
DELIVERED WITH THIS TEMPORARY
MEASURE IN MAKING IT PERMANENT
WILL DO NOTHING BUT FURTHER TO
INCREASE THEIR ACCESS. BECAUSE
THE- AS ABC HAS PROVEN AND
THEY'RE IMPORTANT EFFORT- I
NEEDS ARE NOT BEING CHECKED
REGULARLY AND FOR THE A GAPS
ANIMAL VALLEY COALITION
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB. THREE
EIGHTY NINE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NUMBER ALL. THE EXHAUST ALL
OF YOUR IN Q. OPERATOR. IT THAT
SAID THEN WE WILL HAVE TO
RETURN OURSELVES TO THE
COMMITTEE. FOR ANY COMMENTS
TIONS FROM THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. DO WE HAVE ANY.
THERE WE ARE OKAY. AND THEN WE
HAVE THE DANGER. PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU VICE NEAR- WELL
FIRST OF ALL I THINK THIS BILL
IS REALLY IMPORTANT AS I KNOW
THAT OUR RESTAURANTS ARE THE
ONES THAT ARE BEING IMPACTED
THE MOST. AMONG OTHERS AS IT
PERTAINS TO THE LOSS OF
BUSINESS DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND TEEN I'VE SAT DOWN WITH
MANY RESTAURANT OWNERS SEND
DAVE FONG EXPRESS HOW HARD IT
HAS BEEN FOR THEM TO RECOVER SO
I CAN SEE WHY THE AUTHOR WOULD
BRING THIS FORWARD BOB I HAVE
ONE CONCERN AND- THAT'S JUST.
ME BEING AN EDUCATOR AND DODGES
BEING CONCERNED ABOUT ARGUES
CAN YOU CLARIFY I THOUGHT I
HEARD YOU SAY THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO ADD LANGUAGE AROUND THE
PURCHASE SCENE OF OPERA HELD
FOR MINORS CAN YOU CLARIFY THAT
POINT FOR ME PLEASE. YES AND
RUBIO WE'RE WE'RE WORKING WITH
THE ABC RIGHT NOW ON-
CONSTRUCTIVE LANGUAGE THAT
WILL. GET MORE ACT THAT CLEARLY
RIGHT NOW- IF THIS IF ANYTHING
SOLD IT TO SOMEBODY THAT'S
UNDER TWENTY ONE. THE LICENSEE
MANY THAT RESTAURANT OR THAT
BAR IS HELD LIABLE AND THE
DRIVER IS HELD LIABLE. SO THERE
ARE STANDARDS JUST LIKE THERE
ARE IN THE BAR WHERE THEY HAVE
TO ASK FOR THE DEDICATION. WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO US- YOU
KNOW TO GO FURTHER AND TO WORK
WITH THE ABC AND- TRY TO
DETERMINE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
WAYS WE COULD. MAKE THIS MORE
ROCK SOLID- THE ONE ONE CALL OR-
DID MENTION THAT THERE WERE A
LOT OF PROBLEMS. IT CLEARLY
DOES WORK PROBLEMS EARLY AND
THE ABC WENT OUT EDUCATED- BAR
OWNERS AND EVERYTHING ON THE
APPROPRIATE WAYS OF DOING IT
AND SINCE THEN WHICH IS BEING
PROBABLY A COUPLE MONTHS AFTER
THE COAT THE PANDEMIC STARTED
THERE'S NO MORE INCIDENTS OF
ANY PROBLEMS THEN THERE WAS
BEFORE BECAUSE OF IT. SO I
THINK THAT- WE'RE MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION I FEEL
COMFORTABLE THAT- WILL BE ABLE
TO GET THERE. THANK YOU FOR
THAT- THAT IS THE ONLY CONCERN
FOR ME THAT SOME PENDING BUT I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL BUT I
HOPE TO- YOU KNOW HERE LATER
HOW YOU- AND LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD. AT LEAST FOR MY PEACE OF
MIND HELP CLARIFY THIS POINT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SENATOR
GLAZERS. THANK YOU VICE CHAIR-
YOU KNOW THE PANDEMIC HAS BEEN
A HORRIBLE THING TO LIVE
THROUGH AND IT'S BEEN AN
EQUALLY HORRIBLE THING TO HAVE
IT A BUSINESS TO SURVIVE
THROUGH AND- I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD HIS BILL ALONG
WITH THAT SENATOR WIENER'S BILL
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HEAR IN A
FEW MINUTES AND ANOTHER BILL BY
SUNDERED. FROM NAPA- ARE THAT
TYPE OF THOUGHTFUL AND
PRAGMATIC- ACTIONS THAT WE CAN%
TAKE TO HELP OUR BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE SO- STRUGGLES I THINK
THAT THE PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
AND ARE IN THE BILL OUR
THOUGHTS HAVE BEEN THOUGHTFULLY
DONE TO PROTECT OUR MINERS
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF OUR COMMUNITY AND I APPLAUD
THE LEADERSHIP OF OUR CHAIR AND
HAPPY TO MOVE TO BUILD THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
COMMENT OR- ASK QUESTIONS.
FEDERER THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
GIVE US CLOSE- YES THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR- IT ALSO MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THIS BILL I WOULD BE
CLEAR. THAT WE PUT THE
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE- JUST LIKE
ANY BILLS THE COUNTRY THIS
LEGISLATURE IF WE START
IDENTIFYING PROBLEMS ANY MEMBER
OF THIS BODY THE SENATE BODY OR
THE ASSEMBLY BODY COULD BRING.
A- THE BILL BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE- TO REVERSE THE
DECISION THAT- HOPEFULLY WILL
BE MADE TODAY AND THEN WILL BE
MADE ON THE FLOOR IT'S ALL END
UP BEING SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR
THIS IS THE WAY THIS OPERATION
WORKS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE BUT- KIND. THAT IS THE
CLOSED WE HAVE A MOTION.
SENATOR GLAZER HAS MOVED THE
BILL. WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FOR THE REFERRAL THIS BILL
FOR. THANKS COMMITTEE THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE SB THREE EIGHTY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DODD ALL RIGHT DOT HI
NIELSEN HI NIELSEN AYE ALLEN.
HI ALAN PARTRIDGE A LETTER.
ARCHULETA HI BECKER SPORTS.
BRAUGHER LATER LATER I WENT SO
HI HUESO HI JOE HI JONES I
CANNOT MELENDEZ MELENDEZ I PUT.
I PORTANTINO AYE HI RUBIO I.
NOT PRESENT. RIGHT FOR ENTER
GERMAN. IT WAS THE NUMBER
PLEASE THANK YOU THEIR A TENDER
ZERO WILL PUT THAT THE LONG
CALL FOR THE MEMBERS TO. CHAU
ANDERSON DODD THAT'S THE LAST
ONE IS THAT CORRECT I HAVE ONE
MORE DISCUTIR I SB FIVE SIXTY
ONE NUMBER THREE ITEM THREE
FIVE SIX ONE. THIS CHAIRED
MEMBERS THIS BILL SIMPLY ALLOWS
ALCOHOL MANUFACTURERS TO SHARE
A COMMON AREA WITH MULTIPLE
RETAILERS AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
WHEN ALCOHOL MANUFACTURERS AND
ALCOHOL RETAILERS ARE LOCATED
UNDER THE SAME ROOF ALCOHOL
LICENSING LAWS RESTRICT
CONSUMERS FROM ENJOYING
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES FROM BOTH
BUSINESSES AT THE SHARED COMMON
AREA. THIS CREATES FRUSTRATION
WITH CUSTOMERS WHO DO NOT
UNDERSTAND WHY THE MANUFACTURER
DOES NOT ALLOW THEM TO ENJOY
THAT THEIR DRINK WITH THE REST
OF THEIR GROUP IT ALSO OPENS UP
THE ALCOHOL MAYBE FACTURE THE
POSSIBLE VIOLATIONS OF THE ABC
ACT. THIS BILL IS A WIN WIN FOR
BUSINESSES AND CONSUMERS
THERE'S NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE BUT- ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU SENATOR DIED DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS ARE
INDIVIDUALS HERE IN THE GALLERY
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL I SEE NONE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY. IN THE HEARING
ROOM. NOBODY ON HERE IN ROME
AND WE WILL COME BACK HERE DO
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OF
MEMBERS. FOUR COMMENTS. I THINK
YOU NEED TO ASK FOR OPPOSITION
TO IT WILL GET DAY OFF DO WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION HERE I SEE
NONE IN THE GALLERY I SEE NONE.
IN THE HEARING ROOM. AND DO WE
HAVE ANY. MEMBERS OF THE
IRANIAN AND INDIVIDUALS IN Q.
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OFFER THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE OR TO
COMBAT IN OPPOSITION. AND JUST
AS A REMINDER OF STATE DO YOU
HAVE A COMMENT OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. COMMITTEE
MICHAEL SKIPPER ON BEHALF OF
ALCOHOL JUSTICE. WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB FIVE SIX
ONE. BECAUSE IT CONTINUES- WHAT
WE THINK IS A DISTURBING
ONGOING TREND IN THE
LEGISLATURE. TO ATTACK
MODIFYING MILK BY IN LOWER
TRIED HEALTH. TO BENEFIT THE
BOTTOM LINE OF MANUFACTURES AND
RETAILS RETAILERS- THIS REALLY
IS DEATH BY A THOUSAND CUTS.
ARE WITH THE VICTIMS BEING
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY WE.
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR. ANY
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION IN Q. I
KNOW FOR THE LINES IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT THERE ANOTHER FURTHER
HERE DO WE HAVE NOW ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. THE
BILL HAS MOVED BY SENATE HUESO
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION
WOULD YOU PLEASE ANNOUNCE THE
MOTION AND CALL THE ROLL. CLOSE
YOU WANNA CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THIS IS FILE ITEM
THREE SB FIVE SIXTY ONE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE FIRST RE REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
DODD. I THOUGHT I NIELSEN HI
NIELSEN HI ALLEN. AYE ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ARCHULETA AYE
SPECTER GORGEOUS. BRADFORD
GLAZER HI PLEASE R. WESSEL AYE
HUESO AYE JONES HI JONES I
KAMLAGER MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ I.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO AYE
RUBIO AYE WILK. TRANSACTION
BOTH GERMAN BILL THE ON CALL
DILLON BECAUSE THE CHAIR THE TO
PUT THE VERY DIFFICULT BILLS
MISTER THAT YOU'VE THE TAKEN ON
AND HAD A LITTLE OUR PROBLEM
SOLVING WAY GIVING EVERYBODY A
FAIR OPPORTUNITY. TO COMPLIMENT
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTERED NIELSEN AT THANK YOU
FOR SHARING. NOW WE WILL MOVE
TO FILE ITEM. NUMBER EIGHT SB
THREE FOURTEEN. I BELIEVE
CENTER WINNERS ON HIS WAY. HE.
AREA OF. IF YOU'RE A BILL.
TECHNICALLY CAN WE TAKE THAT
CENTER ARCHULETA YOU'RE ON.
THANK YOU MISTER ANDA COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
THE SENATE BILL MR RESEARCH
LARGEST ONE FOR EVERYBODY
THAT'S LISTENING ONLINE WHAT
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN S. B. TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN ARCHULETA PLEASE
PROCEED SIR. THANK YOU AGAIN
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I THANK YOU AND I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
TWO SEVEN SEVEN. I WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE CHAIRMAN
IS COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME TO IMPROVE THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. FOR TOO LONG
OUR OMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
PLAGUED BY THE PERSISTENT
SOUNDS OF EXPLOSIONS THE BOOMS
AND BANGS AND WE HAVE REFERRED
TO HIM AND SHAKING OF WINDOWS
AND DOORS IN THE PATCH RUNNING.
THROUGH THE NEIGHBOHOOD
BECAUSE OF THE ILLEGAL AMATEUR
FIREWORKS DISPLAYS. LOCAL FIRE
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
HAVE BEEN KEPT FROM OTHER
DUTIES HAS THEY ARE BUSY
RESPONDING TO RESIDENTS
COMPLAINTS ABOUT THESE ILLEGAL
AERIAL DISPLAYS AND SALVATORI
EXPLOSIVES NIGHT AFTER NIGHT.
THE RELENTLESS DISRUPTION TO
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITIES ARE DISRUPTIVE AND
UNWELCOME BY EVERY COMMUNITY.
DESPITE INCREASED ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS TO INCREASE PUBLIC
EDUCATION USE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
FINES AND DEPLOYING DEDICATED
INDIVIDUALS TO GO AFTER THESE
THINGS THAT THESE ILLEGAL
FIREWORKS AND THE PATROLS CAN'T
SEEM TO DO THE JOB. TOTALLY THE
BOTTOM OF A LEGAL AREA- ITEMS
AND LOUD EXPLOSIVE REMAIN AT
UNACCEPTABLE LEVELS. ON TOP OF
ALL THIS AFTER SUCCESSFULLY
FINDING. AND CONFISCATING
ILLEGAL FIREWORKS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MUST PAY MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO HAVE THEM SHIPPED
OUT OF STATE AND DISPOSE OF
PROPERLY. EVEN WHEN WE WIN IT
SEEMS THAT WE'RE LOSING. THIS
IS WHY I'M I'M PROUD TO BRING
FORTH SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN AND TWO SEVENTY SEVEN.
PRESENTS A SOLUTION TO GETTING
ILLEGAL FIREWORKS OFF OUR
STREETS. MORE IMPORTANTLY THIS
BILL AMONG OTHER THINGS EXPANDS
THE DEFINITION OF DANGEROUS
FIREWORKS. REQUIRING AND
REQUIRES THAT ANY SEIZE
DANGEROUS FOR SAFER ST
FIREWORKS BE MANAGED BY THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL. REQUIRES
COMMERCIALLY VIABLE FEDERALLY
APPROVED DANGEROUS CONSUMER
FIREWORKS ARE SAFE AND SANE
FIREWORKS THAT ARE SEIZED BE
MADE AVAILABLE FOR SALE BY ANY
CALIFORNIA LICENSE FIREWORKS
IMPORTER EXPORTER. AND FINALLY
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
ALSO INCREASES ANNUAL LICENSING
FEES PAID BY FIREWORKS
IMPORTERS AND EXPORTERS. THIS
INCREASE WILL WILL BE
DETERMINED BY THE VOLUME OF THE
PRODUCT AND THE NUMBER OF
CONTAINERS THEY IMPORT INTO THE
STATE. FURTHERMORE THE BILL
GIVES THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
THE AUTHORITY TO SELL ANY
COMMERCIALLY VIABLE FIREWORKS
SEES BACK TO THE LICENSE
FIREWORK IMPORTER EXPORTER OR
WHOLESALER IF THEY ARE IN GOOD
STANDING. THE REVENUES
GENERATED BY THESE TWO
MECHANISMS WILL BE USED TO
IMPROVE TRAINING AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS FOR STATE AND LOCAL
FIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
ALLOWING US TO ENHANCE OUR
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS. SENATE
BILL TWO SEVENTY SEVEN ALLOWS
THE STATE TO FINALLY TAKE
ACTION AGAINST UNWELCOME AND
FRANKLY DANGEROUS USE OF
ILLEGAL FIREWORKS FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. AND TODAY ONLINE IN
SUPPORT I HAVE TAUGHT DROUGHT
AMERICAN PROMOTIONAL EVENTS AND
DENNIS REVELL TO HELP ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THIS IS A TRIAL YOU MAY
BEGIN. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
TURNED OUT BY SHERMAN NIELSEN
AND INDUSTRY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHAD TROUT
AND ARMED PEOPLE APPEARING ON
BEHALF OF AMERICAN PROMOTIONAL
BEEN SEEK THE STATE'S LEADING
WHOLESALE DISTRIBUTOR OF
CALIFORNIA STATE FARM MARSHALL
APPRECIATE IN CHANGBAI WORKS
UNDER THE BRAND NAME OF TNT
FIREWORKS. THE CENTRE. SAID
ABOUT THIS LEGISLATION THAT HE
SHARED WITH YOU OVER THE YEARS
A LACK OF FUNDS FOR ENFORCEMENT
AND DISPOSAL. HE DROVE THE
UNIFORMITY AND PROPER TRAINING
HAS LED TO THE STATE'S RAPIDLY
GROWING ILLEGAL FIREWORKS
PROBLEM. IN OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN GOVERNOR
BROWN DID A BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL AND MOVED THREE POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS INTO THE
STATE FARM MARSHALL FIREWORKS
ENFORCEMENT AND DISPOSAL FUND
TO FUND ILLEGAL FIREWORKS
ENFORCEMENT DISPOSAL AND
EDUCATION FOR THE BALANCE OF
FISCAL YEAR 200-018-2000
NINETEEN. UNDER NATION HAS
CONTINUED WITH THREE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS REOCCURRING
LINE ITEM IN EACH OF HIS FIRST
THREE STATE BUDGETS. DUE TO
ENVIRONMENTAL RESTRICTIONS
PREVENTING THE DISPOSAL OF
THESE FIREWORKS IN CALIFORNIA
TWO POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
OF THIS BUDGET LINE ITEM OR
BEING DEDICATED TO SHIPPING THE
SPARSELY UTAH OR LOUISIANA
WHERE THEY WERE THEY ARE
DESTROYED. THROUGHOUT THE LOAN
DAHLE FIREWORKS WORKING GROUP
AND THE STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS
HELD BY THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION STATE AND LOCAL
FIRE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES ALL AGREED THAT 90% OF
ALL SEIZE FIREWORKS ARE
COMMERCIALLY VIABLE AND THAT
95% OF THOSE OR NOT. CALIFORNIA
STATE CONSTRAINT WATER
FEDERALLY APPROVED PRODUCTS
THAT ARE LEGAL TO BE SOLD IN AS
MANY AS TWENTY NINE OTHER ST
STE. SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
ADDRESSES THESE CHALLENGES BY
ESTABLISHING THE FIREWORKS
MANAGEMENT AND RE PURPOSING
COMPONENT THAT WILL HELP THE
STATE AND LOCAL LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS MANAGE THE
SEIZING. STORAGE TRANSFER AND
RE PURPOSING OF SEIZE THE LEGAL
PART FEDERALLYAPPROVED
FIREWORKS FREEING UP STATE
RESOURCES TO FOCUS ON THE
ENFORCEMENT AND PREVENTION OF
IMPORTATION OF THESE ILLEGAL
FIREWORKS IN THE CALIFORNIA. WE
ESTIMATE THAT THIS LEGISLATION
WILL SAVE THE STATE FARM
MARSHALL AS MUCH AS TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN ANNUAL DISPOSAL COST
ALONE FREEING UP THIS MONEY TO
BE USED TO FOCUS ON ENFORCEMENT
AT THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL. I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
VOTE ON S. B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
MISTER AVAIL YOU'RE ON. DENNIS
REVELL ARE YOU ON THE LINE. YES
GOOD MORNING SHARE DODD GLACIER
NIELSEN DENNIS REVELL REVELL
COMMUNICATIONS ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN PROMOTIONAL EVENTS IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
AND I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU MR REVELL LET'S MOVE
TO ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY SEEING NONE WHO MOVED
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE IT'S DON'T
BELIEVE IT IS THERE. THANK YOU
NOW WILL MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY BE
THE TELECONFERENCE RIVERS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROPPED INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN. AND JUST AS A
REMINDER THEY NEED TO PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY FIVE
SIX FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CHERYL CASHMAN I WANT THEM TO
LOOK CALIFORNIA AMERICAN SECRET
CONSULTING I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT- SB TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
AND WHAT I HOPE IS THE FIRST OF
MANY MORE BILLS TO COME. TO
WORK ON THE- ILLEGAL FIREWORKS
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA DROUGHT STATE.
WHENEVER NOT GOING TO BE A DROP
EIGHT. IT'S KEY THAT WE FORWARD
ON ANY LEGISLATION REGARDING
ILLEGAL FIREWORKS THAT WE CAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
AND- JUST YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND SEE IF USE OF.
SUPPORT OR NOT PLEASE AT THIS
TIME. GO AHEAD MODERATE. AND
NEXT WE'LL GO TO A LINE SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SEVEN QUARTER ON BEHALF OF
STAND BY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE A NO FOR THEIR
LINES IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU HAVING HEARD
FROM SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION- ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY SEEING
NONE. ALSO SEE NONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. WILL NOW- ASKED OUR
MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO U. S. B. TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN. AND IF THEY
WOULD PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO THIS TIME IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE A NO LINES
COMING IN IN OPPOSITION WELL I.
THANK THOSE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC- TESTIFIED TODAY DO ANY
OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SENATOR
NIELSEN. MR FOR MY ASK THE
AUTHOR A QUESTION. HE'S UP
THERE IT'S GENERAL ARCHER IS
THERE ANY LIMITATION ON THE
RAISING OF THE FIFTY- IS IT-
THERE'S A SUNSET AND THE
RAISING THE FEE ORDER THEY
DESCRIBE HOW HOW HOW IS THE FEE
RAISED FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND
AND- TODD TRIED TO JUMP IN BUT
FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND THE FEE
WOULD BE A DIFFERENT ISSUE. AND
THE AMOUNT WOULD BE A DIFFERENT
ISSUE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO RAISE THE FEE
WE'RE TRYING TO GET A HANDLE ON
ALL THE ILLEGAL FIREWORKS IN
THE FEE IS JUST ONE ELEMENT.
BUT THE DISPOSITION AND
DISPOSAL TOGETHER AND BRINGING
THIS TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC'S
AWARENESS THAT WE AS A STATE
SENATE ARE TAKING ACTION TO
STOP THIS ILLEGAL FIREWORKS AT
ALL. OF OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
JUST AN UPROAR ABOUT. CENTER
DIRECTOR A AND- THE CONCERN I
HAVE IS OVER THE YEARS WE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS CEDED. TO
AGENCIES THE ABILITY TO ON
THEIR OWN VOLITION REYES FEES.
AT THE NOT HAVE TO DO IT
SEPARATELY AND A NEW BILL- SO
THAT WAS A CURIOSITY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. BUT IT'S THE CENTER
HUESO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I'VE BEEN ARE THIS BILL
IMMEDIATELY- RAISE SOME FLAGS
IN TERMS OF MY- VIEW OF HOW WE
NORMALLY REGULATE THINGS IN THE
STATE AND IT JUST SEEMS. ODD TO
ME THAT- OUR GOVERNMENT WOULD
AND GAUGE IN THE RESELLING. OF
CONFISCATED MATERIALS I KNOW IT
HAPPENS WITH AUTOMOBILES AND-
WHEN CERTAIN PROPERTY IS
ENGAGED IN THE- IN THE PROCESS
OF COMMITTED A CRIME ANALYSTS
SO IT'S NOT SO UNUSUAL BUT IN
THIS CASE. IN THOSE CASES-
THOSE MACHINERIES OR EQUIPMENT
OR KIND OF AN ACCESSORY WHEREAS
THIS. THE ACTUAL ILLEGAL
SUBSTANCE- WHICH IS THE. THE
FIREWORKS IS ACTUALLY BEEN- SET
BACK INTO THE MARKET SO WE'RE
SELLING THINGS THAT ARE NOT
AUTHORIZED OUR STATE. TWO OTHER
STATES AND IF THEY'RE NOT
AUTHORIZED IN OUR STATE WHAT
WERE THEY DOING IN OUR STATE TO
BEGIN WITH. AND IF THEY GOT
HERE ILLEGALLY WHAT HOW DO HOW
CAN WE CONTROL AND I KNOW THIS
BILL DOESN'T HAVE THE REALLY
ABILITY TO CONTROL. WEATHER
SOMETHING IS BROUGHT INTO OUR
STATE BUT WE'RE BASICALLY
HAVING TO THE SUPPLY CHAIN.
WHICH CONTINUES THIS- THIS.
CIRCLE OF ILLEGAL ACTIVITY AND
IT'S JUST BASICALLY INCREASING
THE SUPPLY. OF THESE BANNED
SUBSTANCES IS A REASON WHY THE
COMMUTER STATE BECAUSE VERY
LUCRATIVE AND WELL WERE.
SENDING THEM BACK TO THE PEOPLE
THAT WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR
BRINGING HIM HERE IN THE FIRST
PLACE AND I JUST DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO ME I BELIEVE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT REDUCING COSTS SO-
I THERE'S SEVERAL THINGS ABOUT
THE BILL THAT JUST RAISE FLAGS
TO ME I KNOW THAT THERE'S A
PROVISION THAT WILL. THE
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
GOING O LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM
SIXTY FIVE. PERCENT COMING TO
THE STATE WILL BE REDUCED 225%
SO THE STATE NOW WILL HAVE LESS
MORE BILL- LESS MONEY TO
ENFORCE BUT IT'LL PASS IT ON TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS I THINK
THAT'S FAIR. BUT WHEN THE STATE
IS LARGELY. HE- FUNDING THIS
AND SOME OF THOSE- LAWS ARE
LARGELY LOCAL. IT JUST SEEMS TO
ME LIKE- A RECIPE FOR FAILURE
AND I'M I'M JUST CONCERNED. AT
THIS BILL IS JUST KIND OF MAKE
THE PROBLEM WORSE SO I JUST
WANTED TO. I KNOW- MY
COLLEAGUES TRYING TO FIX A
PROBLEM HERE AND HE'S BEING
CREATIVE AND I APPLAUD THAT. I
THINK GENERALLY OF HAVING MORE
REVENUE WOULD MAKE SENSE BUT-
ADDING TO THE SUPPLIER DOESN'T
SO. HOW DO WE HOW DO WE CONTROL-
VALUE WHEN WE'RE GOING TO SELL
THIS BACK TO OTHER STATES A LOT
OF THEM ARE BORDER STAKES
STATES. HOW CAN WE ENSURE THAT
THE SUPPLIES NOT JUST GONNA BE
TRAFFIC BACK INTO OUR STATE AND
LET LET LET'S HEAR FROM OUR
TECHNICAL EXPERT ON DO YOU GUYS
LIKE JOB THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CARE CENTER OR TO LET IT. YES
YOU HAVE A- THE TODD. JUMP IN
ON THIS. BUT SENATOR I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONCERN ONCE AGAIN
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL. HAS THE
AUTHORITY. TO RECEIVE AND
COMPLICATE THE THESE ILLEGAL
FIREWORKS. AND THE DISTRIBUTION
THERE AND TRANSPORTATION. TO
OTHER STATES. THAT IS WITHIN
THE LAW. AND BUT AS FAR AS THE
RECEIVING OR IMPORTING. OF THE
FIREWORKS THAT'S A WHOLE
DIFFERENT ISSUE. THAT I THINK
THE FIRE MARSHAL IN AND OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. ARE ALSO
TRYING TO STOP. AND SO I THINK
IN THE FUTURE PERHAPS YOU CAN
WORK WITH ME AND- AND OF
COURSE- ARE SENATORS THAT.
REPRESENT THE COASTAL AREA THE
STOP THE SHIPMENT. OF SOME OF
THESE ILLEGAL FIREWORKS. THAT
IS A SEPARATE ISSUE- SO IN SOME
OF THE OTHER THINGS YOU HAD
MENTIONED TODD TROUT- WOULD YOU
JUMP IN PLACE. YOU ALSO HAVE
THIS TO REBEL ON FOR TECHNICAL
ISSUES IN IN CENTER HUESO ONE
OTHER THING. IT THE. THE
MANUFACTURERS ARE NOT SENDING
THESE. BILL FIREWORK INTO THE
STATE. WHAT ARE WE HERE FOR THE
TECH TO GO EXPERTEN. AND I'D
LIKE TO HEAR FOR IT'S UNCLEAR
IF THE FIRE MARSHAL IS IN
SUPPORT AS WELL. MISTER ADEL.
YES YES. FIGURE NUMBER ONE THE
THIS BILL ALSO ADDS PROVISION
BID AT ANY LICENSED THE-
PYROTECHNIC PLACE. IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THE PERSON. IN
ANY WAY. THE ILLEGAL
IMPORTATION OF. THE ILLEGAL
FIREWORKS INTO CALIFORNIA. IS
THE SUBJECT OF LOSS OF THEIR
LIVES NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO-
THE BILL RESTRICTS. THE
FIREWORKS FROM BEING. SHIPPED
TO OR JUST DISTRIBUTED IN A
STATE CONTIGUOUS. TO THE STATE
OF CAL. HELLO THIS IS TROUT
AGAIN LET ME IN ALL KNOWN THE
STATE THAT ARE CONTIGUOUS
CALIFORNIA A LOT. AERIAL TYPE
FIREWORKS THE FOR SOME THAT
HAVE BEEN RESERVE. WHERE THEY
ABLE TO SELL THAT- THE MID OF
THE STATE OR THE MIDDLE IN THE
EAST ALLOW AERIAL TO SO. THIS
CALL WOULD GO BACK TO THOSE
STATES WHERE THERE LEGAL AS FAR
AS ADDING TO THE SUPPLY. THE
WHO ARE TRACK- ILLEGAL IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE VERY
WELL. AND VERY WELL OR- AND
WILL STILL CONTINUE TO IMPORT-
BILLS FOR TO- AND- TO BE SOLD
INTO. SO REALLY DOESN'T ADD TO
THE SUPPLY BECAUSE PRODUCTS
WILL GO BACK IT JUST WHERE THEY
WILL BE SOLD BY THOSE OF US ARE
ARE- LICENSE IN IN. THE OTHER
THING TO I THINK IT'S IT IN IS
IT'S WAY TO FIX THE PROBLEM AND
SO. REDUCE IT IS THROUGH AN-
MISTER FARM MARSHALL OFF BUT
UNDER FUNDED FOR YEARS- AND
THEN UNDERS. TWO ABLE TO DO
WHAT NEED TO BE DONE TO STOP
THE FLOW OR LEAST MAY. THE OF
THE LEGALS WE HAVE A MOBILE
CHAMPAGNE FIRE EVER GREAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH FARM ARE
OFFICE WANTED CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THEM IN THE ENFORCEMENT
THE MORE MONEY THAT OUT TO THIS-
OF THAT PLEASE LET MONEY AND
FOR. ANALYSTS MY FOR IT. SO
THIS IS THE SAME TO BE A AT SO
TO A AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S
BEING ON SPOILS AND HERB MONEY
TO GO TO JAIL TO MOURN FOR MY
AND MORE- IT. AN EXPLOSION OF A
HOUSE SO OBVIOUSLY THE FIRE
DEPARTMENTS AND POLICE
DEPARTMENTS WOULD BE IN
SUPPORT. BUT TO ASK
SPECIFICALLY- TO DROUGHT DID
YOU OBTAIN THE SUPPORT OF THE
FIRE MARSHAL. YES WE HAVE.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU THAT
THAT SATISFIES ME JUST SOME
CLOSING COMMENTS SAY I HAVE I
HAVE NOT I THINK LOTS OF
CALIFORNIANS DEAL WITH THIS-
AND ESPECIALLY OF FIREWORKS ARE
USED WITHOUT A PERMANENT
LEGALLY I- ONE DAY A NEIGHBOR
WAS EXPLODING FIREWORKS IN ONE
FELL IN THE BACK OF MY YARD.
SAN DIEGO IS SAYS PARTICULARLY
OF. PRETTY BIG HOT SPOT ALL MY
ALL MY DISTRICT WITH MEXICO AND
OF COURSE IN MEXICO LOTS OF
PRODUCT IS BROUGHT IN.
ILLEGALLY INTO CALIFORNIAN THAT
ADDS TO THE SUPPLY AS WELL SO-
ANYTHING THAT COULD BE DONE TO-
PROPERLY REGULATE THIS AND
INFORM PEOPLE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO CAN THEY CALL. IN IN
THE- IN THE- AREA- IN THE IN
THE CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE. THEY
COME INTO CONTACT WITH SOMEBODY
THAT'S ILLEGALLY EXPLODING. OF
FIREWORKS I MEAN. MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC I MEAN LAST TIME I
HAD THIS. PROBLEM I CALLED THE
POLICE IN THE PROBLEM DIDN'T.
WASN'T WASN'T. AND THERE SHOULD
BE SOME KIND OF. WAY TO RESERVE
RESOLVE- THESE THESE COMPLAINTS
IN THESE CIRCUMSTANCES IN OUR
STATE SO. I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR- REPLIED MY CONCERNS AND
HOW HOW SUPPORT BILL TODAY.
THAT'S A LARGE LETTER WOULD YOU
TO CLOSE. WE HAVE ANOTHER. YES
THAT'S I DIDN'T SEE YOUR HAD A
THAT'S OKAY YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN I JUST. WANTED TO SEE
BACK TO THE CORE THAT WAS PUT
BY NEW BECAUSE DON'T I'M NOT
CLEAR ON WHAT THE WAS THERE IS
A FEE- AND FEEDER IS BEING. AND
THEN THERE'S ALL A FEE WHERE
THE CAP IS BEING. I KNOW
THERE'S CONCERN. ABOUT THOSE
ELEMENTS OF THE BILL SO I- IF
THE GOOD SENATOR KIDS TO THE TO
SPUR IS BE- YOU KNOW REMOVING A
CAP OF COURSE- ALWAYS BECAUSE
CONCERN THAT SOME. YOU KNOW
IT'S TO CAUSE A FINANCE
HARDSHIP FOR THOSE WHO RELY ON
THESE TYPES OF PRODUCTS FOR
THEIR COMMUNITY- EVENTS AND
FUNDRAISING AND I ALWAYS HAVE A
CONCERN WHEN THERE IS. NO CAP
AT ALL ON A FEE BECAUSE IT
CALLS INTO QUESTION HOW YOU.
ARRIVE AT THE AMOUNT THE FEE IS
SET TO BEGIN WITH SO M. IF THE
AUTHOR COULD ADJUSTED THAT WAY
I WOULD. APPRECIATE THAT. THANK
YOU SENATOR. PER SHARE ME. AND
PLEASE YES. A OUR CONCERN IS.
THE INFO. CONFERENCE OF THE
LEAGUE FIRE. THE FEES OVERHEAD
TURNED OVER TO- TALK. TO A SEC.
BUT WHATEVER WE CAN DO. TO
BRING DE THE USE. OF THE-
FIREWORKS THIS IS WORK WE'RE
TRYING DO- AND A LOT OF A IN
OUR TO. YOU HAVE THE SCOUTS.
AND DIFFERENT CIVIC GROUPS.
THAT RELY ON SO AND SANE. FOR
TO- REYES FUNDING SOMEONE. THE
IS NOT WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
WE'RE AT THE- FOR. INTO TAKE
ACTION WITH. THE MAIN THING.
WITH IN REFERENCE THE FEE SH-
TROUT- OR DINNER REVEAL YOU
HAVE AN- COM OF COURSE ARE ON
THAT. YES YES IS THIS IS DENNIS
WILL- THERE ARE. TWO FEES THAT
ARE DRESSED IN MISSOULA. ONE IS
THE P. THAT IS FOR THE TEST-
PRODUCTS AS THE ARE EITHER OR
OR NOT BECAUSE FIVE AS STATE
FARM SAID. RICHARD UP TO SPEED
WITH THE PRACTICE THE SECOND
FREE. THIS CONTEMPLATED MID IN
THIS LEGISLATION OR DISCUSSED
IS THE FREE ON IMPORTER
EXPORTERS AND WHOLESALERS ONLY
NOT ON THE RETAIL PERMITS
ISSUED TO THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION AND THAT THAT
PREVIOUS FUND THE LOCAL. THE
FIRE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
PERSONNEL ON THE PROPER
HANDLING STORAGE AND PROCESSING
FIREWORKS. THE BASIS IN THEIR
JURISDICTION. SO COULD I JUST
FOLLOW UP AND- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN IS THERE REASON THAT
THERE IS. NO NO CAPITAL I MEAN
WHY WHY WAS THE CAP REMOVED IS
THERE IF THERE IS AN ISSUE OF
THE COST NEEDING TO BE
INCREASED- I'D I'D CERTAINLY
CAN UNDERSTAND WHERE THAT WOULD
COME FROM BUT THE CAP HAS BEEN
COMPLETELY REMOVED MEANING
THERE'S NO CEILING WHATSOEVER
AND I WONDER. WHY THE BILL IS
STRUCTURED THAT WAY IF THE
AUTHOR WOULDN'T MIND-
ADDRESSING THAT. IN ONCE AGAIN
I'M GOING TO DEFER TO- OUR OUR-
THAT DEBT TRAP AND A DENVER
BILL. BUT AGAIN- I HAD POINTED
OUT THAT THE FEES WILL BE
DETERMINED BY THE VOLUME. OF
THE PRODUCT IN THE NUMBER OF
CONTAINERS THAT ARE IMPORTED.
SO THAT AND THAT IS THE MAIN
ISSUE BUT- DENISON- TED PLEASE
JUMP IN. BY THE END OF OKAY
AGAIN IT- THERE CERTAINLY
THERE'S NO REASON WHY TAP CAN'T
BE PUT ON- THE- TESTING FOR
YOUNG ON THE PRODUCT. IT IS NOW
IT IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN IT'S
FIFTY DOLLARS PER ITEM WHICH
TESTED- WERE IN THE PAST BY
STATUTE STEM- SO YOU CAN SEE ON
WHICH IS INCREASE THE SENSE.
THE LEGISLATURE WAS FIRST
CREATED- AS FOR- THE- FREE ON
THE IMPORTER EXPORTER AND
WHOLESALERS- BUT A- THAT IS
LEFT UP TO THE STATE FARM
MARSHALL SAID THAT. DEPENDING
ON WHAT THE COST OF THAT
PREMIUM IS- QUESTION. OKAY ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS ANSWERED JONES
YEAH SO I JUST WANNA VERIFY IF
I HEARD CORRECTLY ON THAT LAST
STATEMENT THAT THE FEE IS BASED
ON THE ACTUAL COST OF RECOVERY
SO THERE IS THERE IS A THERE IS
A NEXUS BETWEEN THE FEE AND THE
ACTIVITY IN THE AND THE FEE IS
CONSTRAINED BY THAT THE ACTUAL
COST OF THE ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES ACT. IS THAT WHAT
I'M HEARING. IT'S THE COST OF
THE RAINING ACTIVITY- THE
DREAMS BILL CONTEMPLATES A NEW
FUND FOR- TRAINING OF LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND FIRE PERSONNEL
ON THE PROPER. WAYS TO SEIZE
HANDLES THE STORAGE AND CRISIS
THE FIREWORKS THE BUSY SEASON
THEIR JURISDICTIONS IT WOULD
ALL BE PART OF THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL IN CALGARY. REGIONAL
TRAINING PROGRAM THAT THEY
ALREADY PROVIDE ON A VRIETY OF
SUBJECTS OF THIS COULD JUST BE
ONE NEW COMPONENTS ADDED TO
THAT- CRISIS THAT IS ALREADY IN
PLACE BUT IT WOULD. BE SPECIFIC
TO THE- PROPER HANDLING OF
CEASE FIRE THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR AT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE BECAUSE IT IS IMPORTANT
YOU KNOW THE FEES IMPORTANT IS
KINDA YOU KNOW IT IT TIPPING
POINT FOR SOME OF US- I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BUT- YOU
KNOW I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S A
WAY FOR THE- AUTHOR TO. YOU
KNOW PUT OUT SOME INFORMATION
THAT. KIND OF CONDENSES ALL
THIS DISCUSSION INTO ONE IN A
COUPLE OF POINTS THAT ARE
EASIER TO EASY TO DIGEST SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
JONES I THINK THAT- THE AUTHORS
HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR THAT
THAT'S GOING TO NEED TO BE DONE
WHEN THE- WHEN THIS THING COMES
BACK- TO THE FLOOR IF IT SHOULD
PASSED TODAY. ANYBODY ELSE
WISHING TO ADDRESS- ON THIS
BILL IS THERE A MOTION. FINNER
JONES MOVES. BUT CAN WE OF. SEE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
RE REFER TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THIS IS FILE ITEM TEN SB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN DOT FIVE DOT HIGH
NIELSEN. NIELSEN AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA I'D
BAKER FORGES ALL RIGHT BORDERS
AYE BRADFORD ALL RIGHT BRADFORD
AYE GLAZER. GLAZER AYE WESSEL
WHAT'S SO I JONES. JONES I
KAMLAGER MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
PORTANTINO RUBIOHI RUBIO AYE
WILK. THAT IS TEN VOTES DID NOT
BILL WILL BE PLACED ON CALL FOR.
THANK YOU RICHARD THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA MOVE- TO SEND IT
BACK TO SENATOR WIENER- THAT
WOULD BE FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
SB THREE FOURTEEN. AS SOON AS
THE- PODIUM IS SANITIZED TO
BLAST CENTER WIENER NOW TO COME
FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN NOT AT FIRST I WANT TO
START BY THANKING- THE-
COMMITTEE- AS WELL AS- MISTER
CHAIRMAN YOU AND YOUR STAFF
FOR- WORKING CLOSELY WITH US
ON. THIS LEGISLATION FOR
HELPING US CRAFTED IN REFINERY
PRE SHOULD OF THE TIME AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE HAS PUT INTO
WORKING WITH US. SENATE BILL
THREE FOURTEEN IS ONE OF TWO
BILLS I'M AUTHORING THIS YEAR
TO PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED RELIEF
FOR CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL
RESTAURANTS AND BARS TO ENSURE
THEY'RE ABLE TO RECOVER
ECONOMICALLY AFTER THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AS I THINK
EVERY MEMBER OF THIS BODY KNOWS
HOW TO PANDEMIC HAS DEVASTATED
MANY SMALL BUSINESSES AND
PARTICULARLY IN THE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY. THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
AND ALARMING RATE SINCE THE
FIRST DAY AT HOME ORDER THE
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY HAS
SUSTAINED THE BIGGEST ECONOMIC
TO. CONTINUES TO STRUGGLE TO
REGAIN WHAT WAS LOST SO MANY OF
CLOSE BARS RESTAURANTS CAFES
ATTAINMENT MENUS AND FOR THE
ONES THAT HAVE SURVIVED MANY
ARE HANGING ON BY THEIR
FINGERNAILS. EVEN NOW
RESTAURANTS AND BARS CONTINUE
TO TOGGLE BETWEEN BEING OPEN OR
CLOSED OR LIMITED CAPACITY OR
INDOOR OUTDOOR IT'S A CONSTANT
SHIFT AND WE NEED TO DO THIS
FOR THE PANDEMIC BUT IT'S BEEN
VERY HARMFUL TO THESE
BUSINESSES SO MANY HAVE CLOSED
PERMANENTLY AND SO MANY ARE
SUFFERING. SMALL BUSINESSES
EMPLOY MORE THAN A THIRD OF
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE AND A
CHUNK OF THAT OUR SERVICE.
WORKERS IN THE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY. OCTOBER NINETY A
LIMITED A STATE SOURCE OF
INCOME THIS PART- AND WE NEED
TO GET THIS INDUSTRY. CONTACT
RESTAURANTS AND BARS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ARE IN NEED OF
FLEXIBILITY- WITH SOME OF OUR
STATE ALCOHOL LAWS SINCE SOME
OF THESE LAWS ARE ANTIQUATED.
MANY OF THESE WERE WRITTEN A
LONG TIME AGO AND JUST SIMPLY
NEED TO BE UPDATED AND- THIS IS
NOW AN OPPORTUNITY. TO DO THAT.
BUT WHEN THE DUST SETTLES OF
THE PANDEMIC MANY OF OUR LOCAL
BUSINESSES WILL CONTINUE TO BE
ONE STEP AWAY FROM CLOSING- AND
USING THESE RULES WILL HELP
THEM RECOVER. SB THREE FOUR
TEAM PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY FOR
LOCAL RESTAURANTS AND BARS IN
SEVERAL WAYS- FIRST- WE KNOW
THAT- THE- OUTDOOR DINING
EXPANSION THAT EDC AUTHORIZED
AS PART OF AN EMERGENCY ORDER.
HAS BEEN A HUGE SUCCESS IT HAS
ALLOWED CITIES AND ALL OF THIS
IS AT THE DISCRETION OF CITIES-
TO- EXPAND OUTDOOR DINING- IN A
WAY THAT ALLOWED SO MANY OF
THESE BUSINESSES TO SURVIVE-
AND THAT ACTIVATED PUBLIC
SPACES- IN A VERY VERY POSITIVE
WAY AND I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE. WHO HAD NEVER REALLY
SEEN THIS BEFORE IN OUR STATE-
HAVEN'T REALLY BECOME THROUGH
THE I. SIX SUPPORTERS IN MANY
COMMUNITIES WANT TO CONTINUE-
THIS OUTDOOR- EXPERIENCE. LARA
AND SO THE BILL- WILL.
AUTHORIZE ABC TWO EXTENDS THE
OUTDOOR DINING- PROVISIONS FROM
THE EMERGENCY ORDER- MINE AFTER
THE END OF THE STATE OR- AND I
WILL THEN CREATE SPACE FOR
THESE BUSINESSES- TO APPLY IF
THEY CHOOSE. TO MATE- THAT-
LICENSE EXPANSION BOB PERMANENT
RATHER THAN FORCING THEM TO GO
THROUGH A FIRE DRILL JUST AS
THEY ARE RECOVERING DO IT- TO
COMPLETE THAT PROCESS BEFORE
THE END OF THE STATE EMERGENCY
ACTIVISM- AN EXTRA TWELVE
MONTHS- AND IF THEY HAVE THEIR
APPLICATION AND BY THE END OF
THE TWELVE MONTHS. IT C. CAN
CONTINUE TO ALLOW THEM TO
OPERATE UNTIL THE LICENSE UNTIL
THE APPLICATION.
IS DISPOSED OF.
I SEE SOME OF LOCATION THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO DO IT. MORE
FREQUENTLY- IT ALSO CREATES
SOME ADDITIONAL TIMING
FLEXIBILITY- FOR- FOR- ONE TIME
EVENTS ARE FOR LIMITED ADVANCE-
ONE OF BEEN YOU LOOK AT OUR
TEAM AND THEN YOU- IS APPLYING.
FOR PARTICULAR- DE. UM AND THEN
THESE CHANGES ARE COLLEAGUES
ARE I THINK OUR CALL SO. GOOD
GOVERNMENT BILL OUT IN THE
STREET OR THE GIVES MORE FOR-
AND I RESPECT ASK FOR I DO. OUT
WITH ME TODAY. IS OF THE BILL
IS LAW THOMAS FROM THE GATE
BRIDGE IS. MISTER THOMAS YEAH
IF YOU CAN HEAR ME YOUR HONOR
YEAH. OKAY YOU NOW I CAN HEAR
YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME OK YES
PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY GREAT OKAY
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LAURIE
THOMAS AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE GOLDEN GATE
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION. WITH
SERVICE OF MOISTURE FOR EXAMPLE
CRYPTO RESTAURANT COMMUNITY
WE'VE ADVOCATED THE PAST YEAR
PER POLICIES TO ENSURE THAT OUR
INDUSTRY AND HAD A CHANCE
MAKING IT THROUGH THE END PLAN
HARDSHIP CAL. PANDEMIC IT'S
BECAUSE THAT INTO FRANCISCO
BEFORE CO WE A SIXTY THOUSAND
FOOD- WORKERS AND OUR STAFF AND
OVER TO NINE THREATS CAFES. NOW
ABOUT 50% THOSE COMPARTMENTS
CLOSE AND MY OTHERS ARE STILL
SHOW WAITING FOR AID AND WILL
OF I'M MORE CONSTRAINTS. THIS
IS AN- WITH STIFF TIGHT MAR.
BECAUSE THEY AN AVERAGE. WAS
LUCKY KEEP BY PERCENT ON EVERY
AND DOOR. AND MANY HAVE
ATTEMPTED CONNECTED FINANCIAL
LOSSES. WE KNOW THAT RUN ARE.
TO ECONOMY. EMPLOYING- OVER
EIGHT POINT THREE PER OF ALL
EMPLOYMENT OUR STATE PARK OPEN
WITH OVER SIXTY SEVEN. SEVENTY
SIX THOUSAND EATING DRINKING A-
AND WE AND A SINGLE MOTHER IN A-
PEOPLE OF. PART TIME WORKER
YOUNG AND OLD STUDENT AND THEN
MANY WHAT MADE CLEAR THE SENATE.
WE'VE GOT OVER 12% OF
CALIFORNIA FELT TAX REVENUE AND
WE- SO MANY OTHER. LIKE THE
FARMERS AND THEIR WORKERS AND-
BY DEFLATION EXACT THE TYPE OF.
THAT WE RIGHT NOW TO TRY TO
SURVIVE. I SENATOR MATCH ONE OF
THE PREDATORY LOOKED TO BE THAT
YEAR WHAT DO YOU KNOW EXPENSE
OUTDOOR SEATING. ON OUR
SIDEWALKS ARE SPACES AND I LOT.
AND IF THE BILL TO. SERVE CUP
GO AND ALCOHOL BAD. WITH NEW
AND THAT'S WHAT IT HELP HOW
MANY. BARELY. SACRAMENTO FOR
THE ONE YEAR NECESSARY AFTER
THE EMERGENCY ORDER IN ORDER TO
ALLOW FOR MORE PERMANENT
EXPANSION IN THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION. I'M DOING IT
PERMANENTLY YOUR AND FALL
SUPPORT BREAST CANCER HAVEN FOR
OUR COMMUNITIES AND WE NEED TO
SURVIVE THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER. FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THAT THEN TRACKING YOU TO THINK.
ARE THERE ANY- MEMBERS WHICH IT
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY- PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY UP IN THE
GALLERY C. NINE- ROOM ONE
TWELVE C. NINE. WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE THIS MODERATOR
FEW PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. THREE FORTY ONE OF MY
MANAGERS. BRITAIN GERMAN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE FOURTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
FIRST WE HAVE BLINDS SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MOMENT. MODERATOR THERE MAY
HAVE BEEN SOMEBODY BY THE NAME
IS CHOPPY SODOMY- THAT- WAS
PERHAPS WAITING TO TESTIFY IF
HE'S ON A KID EGO FIRST. YES.
IN THE AIR. THAT AND SHE SHE
WORKS FOR ME SO I SPOKE ON
BEHALF OF THE G. JERRY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED. WITNESSES A
SUPPORT ON THE LINE. RIGHT FROM
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR. ONE
MOMENT.
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES WITH. THERE ARE- I'M
TRYING TO GET THEIR LINE OPEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU SORRY.
THE
FROM LINE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. REDMAYNE
REPRESENTING THE TRI COUNTY
CHAMBER ALLIANCE OF VENTURA
SANTA BARBARA AND VENTURA
COUNTY. IS SUPPORT OF THAT-
STILL. THANK YOU N. NEXT LINE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS OF THE MILLIONS OF
MONEY CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF SB. THREE
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU AND NEXT
LINE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
SENATORS ROMANTIC OR ABOUT TO
ELLIOT CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF ALAMEDA IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE FOURTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NEXT NINE EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE FOURTEEN THE TWENTY SIX
YEAR. THANK YOU AND NEXT LINE
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS EDDIE ALVAREZ AT THE
END OF IN THE HOSPITALITY
COALITION REPRESENTING
INDEPENDENT RESTAURANT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SB. THREE
ONE FOUR. THANK YOU AND NEXT.
PINE. SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M THIRTY MATHIS
DROPPED OFF ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK. PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO. IN ONE MOMENT PER
NEXT LINE.
NEXT NINE EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN
LYNCH ON BEHALF OF THE NAP ON
BEHALF OF THE NAPA VALLEY
VINTNERS IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
ONE FOUR. THANK YOU. AND THAT
IS ALL THE TIME THANK YOU
MODERATOR. HAVING HER FOR ALL
THE SUPPORTERS WITHOUT FALL THE
SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY-
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY WHICH
WITNESSES NOT IN ROOM TWELVE.
SO WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION THE TELECONFERENCE
RESERVISTS MODERATOR. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE FOURTEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
FIRST FROM NINE EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHRIS SHERMAN DENNIS WILL
PREPARE THE CALIFORNIA BAR
MEMBERSHIP DISTRIBUTORS IN
OPPOSITION WITH. TALKS YEAH.
NEXT IN LINE FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MYSTERY FLANAGAN ON
BEHALF OF WARMINSTER
WHOLESALERS OF CALIFORNIA. I
WANT TO FIRST APOLOGIZE TO OUR
CENTER WE DO FOR THE LATENESS
OR OPPOSITION WATER INSTALL
WEBER ADDRESSING AMENDMENTS
INTRODUCED LAST WEEK- AND WE
SEE THE GENERAL THRUST OF THE
BILL ALRP SPA AND
UNDERSTANDABLE RESPONSE THE
CORPORATE CRISIS BUT THERE IS
ONE SECTION WHICH WE DO OPPOSE.
EXISTING SECTION TO FIVE SEVEN
A LOT OF SPEARMAN TO FRACTURES.
DISTILLERS AND WINERIES. SHARE
COMMENT FOR AND HE SPEAKS. BY
THE PUBLIC. THIS IS A SECTION
IN WHICH YOU PASSED FOR CHANGE
THAT. VALLEY DOES AMENDMENT
CHáVEZ NOW ON RETAILERS TO
BECOME HARDER SUCH. COMMON AREA
AND WE DO OPPOSE SLASH BUT WE
DO TAKE EXCEPTION TO THE NEW
SECTION YOU. CHU WHICH WILL
ALLOW THOSE WATER GENERATIONS
BREWERIES TO ADVERTISE AND
PROMOTE THE BUSINESSES OF THOSE
RETAILERS BEING ADDED THANK YOU
SHARE THE RETAILER'S COST OF
OPERATION WHICH YOU'RE WITHIN
THE SHARED COMMON AREA VENUES.
SUBSIDIZING CONCERT BIOLAGE ALL
APART BASELINE TIED HOUSE LAWS
WE HOPE TO WORK WITH THE
STRATEGY REDRESSING THIS ISSUE
AS IF THE BILL. DOESN'T GO
MODES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
NEXT IN LINE EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS PATTY HOYT
WITH THE ALCOHOL AND DRUG ABUSE
PREVENTION TEAM IN SAN RAMON
VALLEY AND A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL POLICY
ALLIANCE- WE ARE CLOSED THIS
THERE'S TOO MANY THINGS IN IT.
WHAT CAME TO ME TO BE UNRELATED
IT'S NOT JUST EXPANDING OUTDOOR
DINING IN THE SHARED SPACE-
WHICH SEEMS TO. HE IS A BURLY
BLUE LINES ON A LICENSE-
SPECTATOR IT'S THE SENATE ARE
THERE'S TOO MANY THINGS I THINK
THE BILL NEEDS MORE FOCUS. ON
INFILL WE ARE OPPOSED TO
ANYTHING THAT- INFERENCES AT A
DRINKING CULTURE AND NORMALIZES
ALCOHOL. ESPECIALLY AROUND
FUTURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS AMERICAN
VETERANS I'M CALLING AS
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL POLICY
ALLIANCE WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
THREE FOURTEEN IT ENABLED THE
EXTENSION OF THE TEMPORARY WHAT
THE PUBLIC TO BE TEMPORARY
REGULATIONS AND IT'S ALREADY
COMPROMISING OUR LOCAL CITIES
AND THE LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT EXISTS. FOR IT IF OUTDOOR
DINING EXPERIENCE IT IS
SPECIFICALLY ENDANGERING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WITH
DISABILITIES THERE'S NO ADA
COMPLIANT WITH A LOT OF WORK
THAT NEEDS AND WE REALLY NEED
TO TAKE A CRITICAL LOOK AT HOW
PRETENDING THAT THEY LOOK
BILLION ALCOHOLIC. I KNOW THE
NUMBER OF LOCATION AND ACTUALLY
PUBLIC SPACES IN ALREADY. GREEN
BAY DEFICIENT COMMUNITIES WITH
POOR PUBLIC WALKWAYS THIS IS
DEFINITELY A THREAT TO PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THIS IS A THREAT FOR
SAFETY WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
HOW THIS IS BEING PROMOTED HOW
THIS IS PROMOTING MORE OUTDOOR
DRINKING WHERE PEOPLE THAT ARE
CHOOSING TO BE SOBER NOW ARE
BEING EXPOSED TO IT THROUGH
ADVERTISING. AND VERY EXPLICIT
CONSUMPTION OF ALCOHOL. IN THE
PUBLIC SPACE. SO WE ACTUALLY A
VERY CRITICAL LOOK AT THE BILL-
WE PROBABLY IT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT IN LINE EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MICHAEL SKIP ON BEHALF OF
ALCOHOL JUSTICE. I'D LIKE THE
FIRST DAY THAT THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS ON ALCOHOL THAT
OFFER. PROTECTION FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY ARE NEVER
ANTIQUATED. AND WHILE THIS BILL
FOCUSES ON RELIEF AND RECOVERY
FOR BUSINESSES THAT SELL
ALCOHOL WHEN WILL WE SEE
LEGISLATORS FOCUSED ON RELIEF
FROM ALCOHOL RELATED HARM. THIS
STATE SUFFERS MORE OF THAT IN
ANY OTHER STATE ONCE AGAIN OVER
TEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
ALCOHOL RELATED DEATHS THIRTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN TOTAL
COSTS FOURTEEN POINT FIVE
BILLION IN STATE COSTS ALONE.
THIS BILL WILL ONLY MAKE THOSE
NUMBERS WORSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU VOTE NO ON S. B. THREE
FOURTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT FROM NINE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS SPREAD JONES ON THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON ALCOHOL
PROBLEMS IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THANK YOU- THANK YOU BE
MORE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH JUST
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION IN
ITS USE. AND IN YOUR OPPOSITION
LISTING YOUR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CONTINUE. THANK
YOU NEVER THOUGHT THAT I HAD IN
Q. OKAY DO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SENATOR JONES. JUST A REAL
QUICK QUESTION BECAUSE ONE OF
THE ELEMENTS AND I DON'T HAVE A
FULL UNDERSTANDING ON ON THE-
THE- PERMIT FROM THE THIRTY TO
NINETY DAYS ON INVITATION ONLY
EVENTS- CAN YOU EXPLAIN THAT I
DON'T I DON'T. ANDERSON PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT I'VE GOT IS-
IT'S A VERY TECHNICAL ISSUE-
AND ACTUALLY THERE'S A DRAFTING
ISSUE WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO-
IF THINGS GO WELL TODAY WE'RE
GONNA FIX IT APPROACH TO
REALLY- CLARIFY WHAT IT'S
DOING- RIGHT NOW WE IT THE GOAL
IS TO GIVE MORE FLEXIBILITY FOR
WHEN THEY CAN APPLY FOR THE
PERMIT ALLOWING THEM TO APPLY
AS EARLY AS NINETY DAYS. IN
ADVANCE RIGHT NOW- IT DOES IT
IS SOMETIMES THERE'S ALWAYS A
PERCEPTION THAT THEY CAN'T
APPLY UNTIL THIRTY DAYS BEFORE-
AND WE WANT TO MAKE OF THIS FOR
BOTH THE AGENCY AND FOR THE
APPLICANTS AS FLEXIBILITY THAT
THEY CAN DO IT EARLIER SO IT'S
NOT A FIRE DRILL AT THE END
OKAY THAT MAKES A LOT OF I
DON'T HAVE TO BE RUDE RUDE
ROUTE TO THEIR SOME DRAFTING
ISSUES WITH THAT CLICK THAT
YEAH THERE'S A- AND I'M HAPPY
TO MAKE A MOTION. FOR THE BILL.
MISTER IT ELSE WISHING TO
ADDRESS CENTER MELENDEZ. I'M
THINKING CHAIRMAN I JUST WANT
TO MAKE COMMON AND THANK AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD I
THINK THAT- THE LAST YEAR HAS
CERTAINLY SHOWN IS THAT THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT WAYS
THE BUSINESS'S CAN OPERATE AND
CERTAINLY THESE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES LICENSEES HAVE SHOWN
THAT THEY CAN OPERATE LEGALLY
AND SAFELY IN THIS MANNER AND I
SEE NO REASON WHY THEY CAN'T
CONTINUE TO DO SO. GIVEN THAT
WE HAVEN'T HAD- THE HOST OF
PROBLEMS THAT SOME MIGHT
SUGGEST ARE TO COME IN THE
FUTURE SO WITH- WITH THAT I DO
WANT TO OFFER MY SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL. THANK YOU CENTER
WIENER WHICH LIKE CLOSE. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
I DO JUST WANT TO KNOW ONE
THING THE- WHOLESALERS
DISTRIBUTORS WHO IT CALLED AND-
ABOUT THAT SHARING ARRANGEMENT
AND SPECIFICALLY IT WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO IMPACT THE TIED HOUSE
LAWS. WE'RE GOING TO WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND STAKEHOLDERS-
FOR APPROPRIATIONS IF THINGS GO
OUT TODAY- TO- TO DO SOME
CLARIFICATION I PROVISIONS SO.
WERE ARE MY HOPES TO RESOLVE-
RESOLVE THAT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR JONES THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE FIRST RE REFER TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHT- SB
THREE FOURTEEN. OUR DAUGHTER HI
DOT HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN AYE
ALLEN ARCHULETA HI RICHARD I
BAKER GORGEOUS. BORDERS AYE
BRADFORD. LATER HI LATER I WAS
SO JONES I DON'T I KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ HI MELENDEZ AYE
PORTANTINO. RUBIO HI RUBIO AYE
WILK. BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES-
BEYOND THE- REPORTER PUT THE
PLACE THE BILL ON CALL. NOW
WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
CENTER WINNER YOU MAYBE GET- I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN- AND AGAIN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN TO COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON-
THIS BILL THESE ORINDA IT IS A
GOING TO BE ONE BILL IN THE
COMMITTEE I THINK WISELY
BECAUSE THIS IS SPLIT. INTO TWO
BILLS ARE TO MAKE IT'S ONE MORE
MANAGEABLE WE'RE HAPPY TO DO
THAT AND I'M HAPPY TO- EXCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- AND I
SAYS SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
WHICH IS THE SECOND. RELIEF
BILL- FOR OUR HOSPITALITY
SECTOR- IN LIGHT OF COATED SIDE
SPECIFIC- TWO OR IT REALLY
FOCUSES ON A LIVE MUSIC VENUES.
AND SO DOES A FEW THINGS FIRST-
CREATE OUR LIVE MUSIC VENUES OF
COURSE- IF YOU LOOK AT THE
SUFFERING OF RESTAURANTS AND
BARS. LIVE MUSIC VENUES ARE
ABOUT THREE NOTCHES ABOVE THAT
IN TERMS OF SUFFERING- THEY
COULD THEY SHUT DOWN THE MINUTE
THE SARTED THE PANDEMIC- AND
THEY HAVE YET TO REOPEN- THEIR
DAY ON LIKE THE RESTAURANTS
THAT ARE AT LEAST BEEN ABLE TO
PARTIALLY REOPEN A PERIOD OF
TIME. LIVE MUSIC VENUES ARE
JUST REALLY AT RISK- THEY'VE
GOTTEN SOME RELIEF FROM
CONGRESS WHICH IS GREAT- BUT WE
REALLY LET'S TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP THEM
RECOVER QUICKLY. AND ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES IS EVEN THOUGH WE
HAVE ALMOST I THINK AROUND
NINETY- ALCOHOL LICENSE TYPES
IN CALIFORNIA WITH US YOU DON'T
HAVE AN ALCOHOL LICENSE TYPE
SPECIFIC TO LIVE MUSIC VENUES
OF A HAVE TO SHOEHORN. INTO
ANOTHER KIND OF LICENSE AND
THEY FREQUENTLY WILL DO THAT.
THE BEST PATTERSON CURRENTLY IS
TO GET ON A RUN A FULL
RESTAURANT LIQUOR LICENSE WHICH
REQUIRES THEM TO HAVE A FULL
KITCHEN- OR YOU KNOW EVEN
THOUGH THEY'RE NOT A
RESTAURANT- AND SO WHAT THAT
MEANS ACCOUNTING FOR SO IT'S
VERY EXPENSIVE TO BUILD OUT A
COMPLETE KITCHEN- BUT SECOND IT
REALLY LIMITS THE KINDS OF
SPACES. BUT A LIVE MUSIC VENUE
CAN GO INTO BECAUSE OF ITS NOT
OF THIS WILL NOT COMEDY A FULL
RESTAURANT KITCHEN- THEY-
REALLY CAN GOING LIVE YOU. IS
SUCH AND PART OF OUR CULTURE-
AND- IN OUR CITIES AND THE
DISTANCE ELISE CHRISTODOULIDES
SENDS. FOR THE LIVE MUSIC
VENUES IT'LL THE FEE WON'T GO
DOWN- BUT IT'LL JUST CREEK GIVE
THEM. SOMETHING THAT FRANKLY WE
SHOULD'VE DONE A LONG TIME AGO-
THE OTHER. PIECE OF THIS BILL-
IS IT. HAS TO DO WITH- THE SORT
OF THE CITIZENS OPEN CONTAINER
LAWS. AND I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT WE'RE NOT INVENTING THE
CONCEPT OF OPEN CONTAINERS OWNS
FOR CITIES IF THEY CHOOSE THEY
CAN DO THAT RIGHT NOW. BUT WHAT
IT IS DOING IS CREATING MORE
FLEXIBILITY SO THAT OUR LOCAL
BARS AND RESTAURANTS. IT OPENED
HIS OWN CONVERTED TO PAID. TO
BE CLEAR THE CURRENT LAW.
ALLOWS CITIES TO AUTHORIZE OPEN
CONTAINER SO IF THE CITY HAS A
STREET FESTIVAL OR A- FESTIVAL
IN THE TOWN SQUARE THEY
DESIGNATE AND AN AREA OF THE
CITY. AS SOME SORT OF
ENTERTAINMENT ZONE. I CITY
RIGHT NOW CAN ALLOW OPEN
CONTAINERS AND THAT'S BEEN THE
LAW FOR. FOREVER OR NOT FOREVER
BUT. YOU KNOW GOING BACK
DECADES AND DECADES. THE WAY IT
HAS TO HAVE NOW. IS YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A- COME IN AND GO TO
TEMPLE ALCOHOL PERMITS AND SELL
FROM. A STANDARD OR A TRUCK OR
WHATEVER. AND EVEN IF THERE'S A
BAR RESTAURANT THAT'S LITERALLY
RIGHT THERE IN THE ZONE.
THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
PARTICIPATE AND SELL AN OPEN
HAVE SOMEONE TAKE OUT OF YOUR
BEER OR WHATEVER. AND SO THE
OUTSIDE VENDORS CAN COME IN AND
OUT OF IT. BUT THE BAR
RESTAURANT THAT'S RIGHT THERE
AND IS INTEGRATED INTO THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY CANNOT. AND SO
WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO IS TO
SAY WHEN YOU CREATE AN OPEN
CONTAINER ZONE FOR YOUR ANNUAL
PARADE OR STREET FESTIVAL OR
WHATEVER- IF YOU CAN THE CITY
DOESN'T HAVE TO BOOK AN
AUTHORIZED. THE BARS AND
RESTAURANTS RIGHT TO
PARTICIPATE. AS WELL SO IT'S
NOT CREATING THE IDEA OF AN
OBJECT CONTAINERS ON. BUT IT'S
ALLOWING OUR LOCAL SMALL
BUSINESSES- TO PARTICIPATE
THOSE BARS AND RESTAURANTS OF
COURSE DON'T HAVE TO DO IT- BUT
THEY'LL AT LEAST BE ABLE TO DO
IT WITHOUT VIOLATING. OTHER
LIQUOR LICENSE- AND AGAIN THIS
IS TOTALLY IN THE DISCRETION.
OF CITIES THEY ALREADY HAVE
THAT DISCRETION OVERSIZED
ALLOWING THEM TO ALLOW THE
LOCAL SMALL BUSINESSES. TO
PARTICIPATE BY SO WITH THAT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. AND WITH ME- ENERGETIC.
OVER THE PHONE LINE TODAY TO
TESTIFY. IS ALEX TO AS
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
INDEPENDENT VENUE ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
BELIEVE HE'S IN THE HOUSE AND
ALWAYS IN THE HOUSE OF MY GOD.
POLICE ARE SEEKING THE STORES.
THANK YOU CHAIR DODD MEMBERS
ALEX TOWARDS THE STRATEGIES
THREE SIXTY HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
INDEPENDENT VENUE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OVER
FOUR HUNDRED INDEPENDENT VENUES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THESE ARE
VENUES LIKE CARLOS JUST DOWN
THE STREET HERE IN SACRAMENTO
THE TROUBADOUR LOS ANGELES THE
FOX THEATER OAKLAND. BLUE NOTE
NAPA MISTER CHAIR AND NOT MANY
MORE. SB SEVEN NINE THREE
BRINGS MUCH NEEDED RELIEF TO
THESE INDEPENDENT VENUES AND-
AS CALIFORNIA WORKS TO BUILD
BACK BETTER INDEPENDENT VENUES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WILL BE
CRITICAL TO A VIBRANT ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. CONTRIBUTED
SIGNIFICANTLY TO CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE VENUES EMPLOYEE TO
WATCH A WIDE NET OF FOLKS MANY
THINK OF THIS INDUSTRY IS ONLY
THE ARTIST ON THE STAGE BUT-
BEHIND THE CURTAINS AS A WIDE
ARRAY OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
DEPEND ON THIS INDUSTRY.
INCLUDING THE ARTISTS LIKE
BARTENDERS- THEATRICAL STAGE
EMPLOYEES SECURITY MANY MORE.
OF THESE MONIES ARE MAJOR
DRIVERS OF TOURISM MEMBERS.
DOLLARS UP AND DOWN THE STATE
FOR THESE ANCHOR BUSINESSES IN
THEIR COMMUNITY A RECENT
ECONOMIC IMPACT STUDY REPORTS
THAT FOR EVERY DOLLAR SPENT. ON
A CONCERT TICKET TWELVE DOLLARS
IS GENERATED IN THE LOCAL
ECONOMY AT BARS RESTAURANTS
HOTELS TRANSPORTATION BRING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ESTIMATED THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW WE BRING
BACK THESE TOURISM DOLLARS TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. HE
TALKED TO MANY RESTAURANT
OWNERS THEY'LL TELL YOU THAT
THEY ACTUALLY LOCATED THERE
RESTAURANT NEXT TO AN
INDEPENDENT VENUE. BECAUSE THEY
ARE ABLE TO GAIN. STREAMERS
FROM THAT FOR TRAFFIC FOR ALL
OF THAT ACTIVE SO. OFF RELIEF A
FOR VENN. YOU'RE REALLY OF A
TIDE REALLY WILL ALL SHE- AND-
UNFORTUNATELY SINCE MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY THESE INDEPENDENT
VENUES HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY
SHUTTERED DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY THE SHUTDOWN. THESE
WERE THE FIRST TO CLOSE AND TO
DATE HAVE ZERO REVENUE GET ALL
THE OVERHEAD COSTS. EVEN IF RE
OPENING GUIDELINES PERMITTED
THE INDUSTRY TO OPERATE AT
1100% CAPACITY TOMORROW THE
SHOW'S WOULDN'T GO ON
IMMEDIATELY. SINCE THE COVERT
SHUTDOWNS INDEPENDENT VENUES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA OR LOSING
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
UPWARDS OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER MONTH.
MANY VENUES ACROSS ALSO CURRENT
TREMENDOUS DEBT TO REMAIN
SHUTTERED. AND WHILE THE
DISTRIBUTION OF A VACCINE AND
THE GRADUAL RE OPENING OF THE
STATE IS ENCOURAGING THE
HEMORRHAGING MONEY WILL LIKELY
CONTINUE FOR AT LEAST ANOTHER
FOUR TO SIX MONTHS. WELL 1100%
CAPACITY INDOOR SHOWS ARE STILL
PROHIBITED DUE TO PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDELINES- HUGETHANK YOU TO
SENATOR WINNER FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. SB
SEVEN NINE THREE WILL PLAY AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN PROVIDING
REGULATORY RELIEF FOR HUNDREDS
OF VENUES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WITH THIS MEASURE AND OTHER
CRITICAL EFFORTS BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE WE ARE CONFIDENT
CALIFORNIA STAGES WILL BE DARK
FOREVER AND THESE ACRE
BUSINESSES WILL CONTINUE TO
CONTRIBUTE. ECONOMICALLY AND
CULTURALLY TO COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I WOULD
ALSO NOTE SENATOR WIENER
REFERENCED- FEDERAL AID FOR-
INDEPENDENT VENUES PASSED AS
PART OF THE SHUTTERED VENUE
OPERATOR. GRANT UNFORTUNATELY I.
NO FOUR MONTHS THE- SIGNING OF
THE PROGRAM MENTAL AID STILL
HAS YET TO OUT FOR VENUES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO. THIS IS A REALLY
CRITICAL EFFORT AGAIN THINK
THANK THE SENATOR FOR HIS
EFFORTS STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT HERE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE NOBODY ELSE IN
THE GALLERY AND NOBODY AND ROOM
ONE TWELVE. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
WHAT WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT VIA
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB. SEVEN NINETY THREE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO BECOME
PART OF THE B. SEVEN NINETY
THREE PLEASE R. ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE WILL START
WITH MINE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CORRECT AT THE END OF
AND THE HOSPITALITY COALITION
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN NINE
THREE WE HAVE ALMOST A HUNDRED
DIFFERENT BY THE VICE THAT NOT
ONE SPECIFIC ENTERTAINMENT
VENUES NO OTHER INDUSTRY HARPER
MORE JOB LOCK YOU TO CALL OF IT
THANK YOU AND I SUPPORT ALL.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE.
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS JIM CORNETTE
OWNER CARLOS IN SACRAMENTO AND
SUPPORTED SB SEVEN NINE THREE.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN NINE THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THE TIME. AND
THAT IS ALL I HAD IN Q. THANK
YOU HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION. SEEING NOBODY IN
THE GALLERY AND NOBODY AND ROOM
ONE TWELVE. MODERATOR IT COULD
YOU PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN NINE
THREE. THANK YOU GENTLEMEN WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
THE B. SEVEN NINE THREE THREE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THE TIME. WE'LL START WITH MINE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL SKIP
ON BEHALF OF THE HALL OF
JUSTICE. WHILE WE CAN
APPRECIATE THE DEEP CONCERN FOR
THE ECONOMIC VIABILITY OF THE
BUSINESSES THIS BILL SEEKS TO
BENEFIT. WE SEE NOTE THE
BENEFIT OF THE STATE OR THE
TAXPAYERS WHO BEAR THE BRUNT OF
PAYING FOR ALCOHOL RELATED HARM
EVERY YEAR. BASICALLY THIS BILL
WILL PROMOTE DRINKING
EVERYWHERE THAT IS THE MODEL OF
BOURBON STREET IN NEW ORLEANS.
CALIFORNIA STREETS WILL MORE
CLOSELY RESEMBLE THE WORST
VARIETY OF STREET FAIR WERE
ALCOHOL'S ALLOWED FOR OPEN
CONTAINERS ARE ALLOWED. AND
THIS IS A LONG BEEN
ACKNOWLEDGED AT THE BAD PUBLIC
HEALTH AND PUBLIC SAFETY
PRACTICE WE ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR NEXT FROM NINE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JONES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL ON ALCOHOL PROBLEMS
DID- TO THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
CONCERNS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AN EXTRA NINE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I REPEAT. HI
MY NAME IS ERICA BETTER I'M
RECORDS I'M THE REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL
POLICY POLICY ONLINE WITHDRAWN
WE OPPOSE SB SEVEN THREE I
WOULD HAVE BIG CONCERNS FOR THE
WAY THAT YOU I WILL BE ALLOWED
TO BE IN THE VENUES THAT IT'S
AN ISSUE THAT HAS NOT BEEN A
DRAG- AND WE REALLY WANT TO
ENCOURAGE OUR LEGISLATORS TO
TAKE A CRITICAL LOOK AT THE
MUSIC THAN YOU MIGHT THINK
WE'LL ALLOW MINORS TO BE INSIDE
OF THE BANK THAT IS. HEAVILY
PROMOTING ALCOHOL AND
ADVERTISING- THIS IS A REALLY
CRITICAL THING FOR US TO
CONFIGURE SPECIFICALLY WANTING
TO ALSO ELIMINATE THE CONCERN
FOR HOW THIS IS AN ATTACK ON
THE ENTERTAINMENT- COMMUNITY
BUT THAT'S BASICALLY THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY THAT BENEFITS FROM A
LOT OF THE BIG SAID THEIR
FREQUENCY BAND TO ENGAGE IN THE
CULTURE- AND MUSIC LIVE MUSIC
ENTERTAINMENT- TRYING TO
PROMOTE ALCOHOL CONTINUOUSLY AS
AN ELEMENT OF OUR CULTURE AND
PARALLEL TO ENTERTAINMENT IS AN
ISSUE IN OUR STATE WE HAVE A
LOT OF DATA THAT SHOWED THE
PROBLEM. WE REALLY NEED TO
QUESTION WHY WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT IT ON THE COMMITTEE RIGHT
NOW AND INSTEAD OF TALKING
ABOUT THE REVENUE AND THE WAY
THAT WE NEED TO SUPPORT THESE
OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE HUGE
ISSUES WITH ALCOHOL ACCESS AND
CONSUMPTION AND ARE HEAVILY
TARGETED BY THE ALCOHOL
INDUSTRY AND THEN HAD THE BILL
IS NOT IN THE DIRECTION OF THE
PORTING OUR COMMUNITY THAT ARE
ACTUALLY STRUGGLING- AND THE
BUSINESSES THAT WILL NOT EXIST
IF YOU PEOPLE DON'T. REALLY
NEED A BETTER COMMUNITY OVERALL
WE REALLY ENCOURAGE AND THEY'LL
CALL US AT SEVEN EIGHTY THREE
THANK. YOU THANK YOU AN
EXTERNAL NINETY ONE. BEFORE YOU
START JUST YOUR NAY YOUR OR-
YEAH- YOUR- THAT WE'VE TAKEN
MINUTES. SO PLEASE. MIND
DROPPED OUT BUT FOR I HAVE NO
OTHER YOU. OKAY THANK YOU MUCH-
CALL OR SUPPORT WITNESSES WE
WILL NOW BE THE DISK BACK TO
MEMBERS ANYBODY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. SEEING NINE
TO CENTER GLAZER MOVES THE BILL
CENTER WE DON'T WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FEDERAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER- WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR GLAZERS. HERE AND WE-
THAT IS. I BELIEVE THAT'S THE
PAST. WE'VE TAKEN SO MANY
PEOPLE OUT OF ORDER HERE SO I'M
NOT SURE- TAKING INTO
APPROPRIATIONS. A NATIVE IT HAS
TO BE AMENDED FIRST. HOW WE-
OKAY SO WOULD YOU- PUT THE- THE
MOTION AND CALL FOR THE VOTE
PLEASE SURE HI THIS IS FILE
ITEM NINE SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST THE MAN AND
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DODD. I START HI
NIELSEN HI NIELSEN HI ALAN
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA BAKER
BORCHERS ON BORDERS AYE
BRADFORD GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE
WESO. JONES I. DON'T I CAN.
MELENDEZ I MELENDEZ AYE
PORTANTINO RUBIO HI RUBIO AYE
WILK. THAT IS EIGHT VOTES BUT I
WILL PUT THAT BILL ON CALL-
WERE FINALLY THREE THE END OF
THE LINE- CENTER LIMóN DOING
THIS- REMOTE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE I DO WANT TO LET
MEMBERS WHO ARE- IN OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBER COMMITTEES OR
IN THEIR OFFICES THEY NEED TO
COME DOWN- BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO KEEP THESE BILLS ON
CALL FOR LONG. THE SERVER
LIMóN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS S. B. SEVEN OH TWO
ESTABLISHES A WORKING GROUP TO
DISCUSS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO ENSURE THE
STATE BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF THE
STATE THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES BY
AUGUST FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AND ANNUALLY THERE AFTER
EIGHT THE REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE WITH AGGREGATE
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION OF
INDIVIDUALS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR. THE BILL REQUIRES THE
REPORT TO BE PUBLISHED ON THE
GOVERNOR'S WEBSITE TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA LEADERSHIP REFLECTS
ITS GREATER POPULATION A
COLLECTION OF DIRECTORIAL
POINTY DEMOGRAPHIC DATA IS
CRITICAL STEP TO ACHIEVING
GENDER RACIAL AND ETHNIC EQUITY
ON BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS THE
ANNUAL REPORT WILL SERVE AS A
TOOL TO IDENTIFIED GAPS IN
REPRESENTATION INCREASE OUR
REACH TO COMMUNITIES AND
ADDRESS BARRIERS TO SEEKING AN
APPOINTMENT. THIS BILL IS
CONSISTENT WITH PREVIOUS
EFFORTS BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE DIVERSITY IN
REPRESENTATION AT ALL DECISION
MAKING LEVELS. TODAY TO TEST
AND OF THE BILL IS ON BEHALF OF
THE SPONSOR HELEN THOUGHT IS
WITH THE SPINOUS OREGON
ORGANIZED FOR POLITICAL EQUITY
ALSO KNOWN AS HOPE AND DOROTHY
SALMON VETERANS ADVOCATE. WITH
TAURUS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PROCEED. THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
MORNING SENATOR DIED IN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS MENTIONED
MY NAME IS HELEN TERCIO HISPANA
ORGANIZED POLITICALLY QUALITY
NOTED HOPE HOPE IS A NONPROFIT
NONPARTISAN ORGANIZATION
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THE
POLITICAL AND ECONOMIC PARITY
ABOUT THE MASTER LEADERSHIP
ADVOCACY AND EDUCATION TO
BENEFIT ALL COMMUNITIES IN THE
STATUS OF WOMEN. FOCUSED PROUD
TO BE A SPONSOR OF THAT B.
SEVEN OH TWO AND ARE GRATEFUL
TO BE WORKING WITH SENATOR
RAMON ON THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC
SB SEVEN A TO SIX TO CREATE
TRANSPARENCY IN GOVERNMENTAL
APPOINTMENT BY REQUIRING THAT
AN ANNUAL REPORT BE RELEASED
THE DEMOGRAPHIC DATA OF ALL
APPOINTMENTS MADE IN THE
PREVIOUS YEAR. THIS REPORT
WOULD INCLUDE IMPORTANT
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA SUCH AS RACE
GENDER ETHNICITY ABILITY STATUS
SEXUAL ORIENTATION THAN CAN
THAT ULTIMATELY THE ANNUAL
REPORT WILL HELP UNDERSTAND THE
DEMOGRAPHIC COMPOSITION OF
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS ACROSS
THE STATE. IT'S ENACTED THE
DATA WILL BE A TOOL TO
HIGHLIGHT FOR DEFECTIVE THE
FESTIVITIES HAPPEN
REPRESENTATION EXISTS AND WHAT
COMMUNITIESINVOICES ARE
MISSING FROM THE TABLE IN
ADDITION TO AN IN THE ANNUAL
REPORT SB SEVEN OH TWO WILL
CREATE A TIME LIMITED WORKING
GROUP THAT IS TASKED WITH
IDENTIFYING BARRIERS AND
SOLUTIONS TO DIVERSIFY THE
APPOINTMENT PROCESS. RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT DIVERSITY IN
GOVERNMENT LEADS TO POLICIES
THAT BETTER REFLECT THE
INTERESTS OF THOSE REPRESENTED
AND AS THE MOST POPULOUS AND
DIVERSE STATE IN OUR COUNTRY
IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
CREATE FORMAL MET MECHANISMS TO
ENSURE THAT A GOVERNANCE CAN
ONLY REFLECTS THE COMMUNITIES
BEING SERVED. HOPEFULLY IS THAT
DEMOCRACY AND GOVERNANCE IS
STRONGER WHEN EVERYONE HAD IT
AT THE TABLE FOR THESE REASONS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IDOL TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU-
DOROTHY SALMON. BARCLAYS ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. WE CAN GO BACK
TO HER OPERATOR SHE- THAT COMES
ON LET'S MOVE THE NEW OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY SCENE
DONE THERE'S ALSO NOBODY IN
ROOM TWELVE WISHING TO TESTIFY-
LET'S MOVE TO- WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR VERSUS
MODERATOR. IN SUPPORT OF S.
EIGHTY SEVEN OH TWO. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. SEVEN OH TWO. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN
OUR FIRST LINE. MY NUMBER
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR BILL OF RIGHTS HEARINGS
FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT AT SB. SEVEN OH
TWO. THANK YOU. NEXT HEADLINE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU L. MY NAME IS ALEXIS
CASTANEDA I'M A CO CONSTITUENTS
IN L. A. COUNTY SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN OKAY. THANK
YOU NEXT WE HAVE NINE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO BUT I
SUSPECT NOT ONLY ON BEHALF OF
HIS BUNIONS ORGANIZED THE
POLITICAL EQUALITY HOPE AND
STRENGTH SB. SEVEN OH TWO.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
B. SEVEN OH TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WILL
NOT FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS
FROM ANY OPPOSITION SEEING NO
WITNESSES THE GALLERY IN SEEING
NOBODY IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WELL
NOW- TURN TO GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. CAN YOU MODERATE CAN YOU
PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION S. B.
SEVEN OH TWO. THANK YOU REMAIN
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF FIFTY
SEVEN OH TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. ANYBODY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN OH TO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AND
I HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR- DO ANY MEMBERS HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON
THIS BILL FEDERAL HUESO. THANK
YOU I JUST WANTED TO MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION TO THE OFF FIRST
OF ALL I WANNA I WANT TO STATE
THAT THIS IS A WONDERFUL BILL I
THINK THIS IS A GREAT BILL MUCH
NEEDED BILL. AND IT'S WAY
OVERDUE SO I WANT TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. HI I DO HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION TO THE AUTHOR
HOWEVER. I DO HAVE A
RECOGNITION TO THE SENATE AND
THE LEGISLATIVE BODY AS A
WHOLE. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
NOT INCLUDED IN THIS BILL IS
ANY. LOOK AT HOW THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH HANDLES APPOINTMENTS TO
JUDGES. AND SINCE THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL WAS ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN THIRTY TWO I THINK
THERE HAVE BEEN. SOME ELEVEN OR
TWELVE APPOINTMENTS OF- LATINOS
SHOULD THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
WHICH IS A BODY OF ABOUT THIRTY
TWO PEOPLE. IF THAT BODY WAS
CURRENTLY REFLECT OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION THERE
SHOULD BE AT LEAST. EIGHT TO
ELEVEN MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL THAT ARE OF LATINO
DESCENT. HOWEVER THERE HAVE
BEEN ELEVEN IN THE WHOLE
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA SINCE
NINETEEN THIRTY TWO I THINK
THAT IS. A WARRANT AND THAT
NEEDS TO CHANGE AND I THINK WE
NEED TO. HOLD THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH'S ACCOUNTABLE- AS THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON MAKING OF
THESE IMPORTANT APPOINTMENTS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO. APPOINT
PEOPLE TO THESE COMMISSIONS
INTO THESE BOARDS THAT REFLECT
THE POPULATION OF PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO HAVE OUR COURTS.
HAVE JUDGES IN IN HIGH OFFICES
AND HAVE MEMBERS OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THAT SIDE. HOW
THE COURTS ARE RUN AND HOW
POLICY IS MADE NOW PEOPLE ARE
HIRED THERE ARE ALSO
REFLECTIVE. OF THE OF THE
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIA AS A
WHOLE NOT NOT I'M JUST NOT
TALKING ABOUT LATINOS AND
TALKING ABOUT ASIANS AFRICAN
AMERICANS. PEOPLE OF THAT
RECALL OF ALL WALKS OF LIFE
MORE STATE. OF CALIFORNIA. AND
AT THAT THE I THINK THERE IS
PLENTY OF TALENT IN EVERY
SINGLE ASPECT OF OUR SOCIETY
AND WE HAVE TO MOVE A LITTLE
BIT HARDER. ON MAKING THAT
HAPPEN SO A SUGGESTION TO THE
AUTHOR PLEASE LOOK AT THIS
BILL. AND WHETHER IT'S
POSSIBLE. TO INCLUDE. THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH MAYBE THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL MAYBE THE
APPOINTMENT OF JUDGES. IN THAT
PROCESS AS WELL SO- I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING IN
THIS AREA AND- AND ENCOURAGED
MEMBERS OF THE OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MR I'D LIKE TO ALSO
CONGRATULATE THE AUTHOR- I'M SO
EXCITED ABOUT SENATE BILL SEVEN
OH TWO I'D LOVE TO BE A CO
AUTHOR AND ALSO I'D LIKE TO-
JUST THANK EVERYONE WHO WAS
INVOLVED IN THIS TO PUT THIS
TOGETHER OBVIOUSLY- TO
ENCOURAGE OUT REGION ARE
COMMUNITIES OF INTEREST FURTHER
WE COULD KNOCK DOWN SOME OF
THESE BARRIERS THERE IS STILL
WORK TO BE DONE AND I THINK
THIS WORKING GROUP. WILL BE
ABLE TO ADVISE THE GOVERNOR ON
THE NECESSITY TO FIND GOOD
LEADERSHIP ACROSS THE BOARD
GOING- INTO OUR COMMUNITIES TO
FIND THAT DIVERSITY IN IT IS SO
NECESSARY AND IF OBVIOUSLY
DIVERSITY AND IN RACE AND
GENDER IDENTITY CLASS RELIGION
CREED AND EVERYTHING TO FEEL IT
SO EVERYONE CAN FEEL PART OF
THE COMMUNITY AND PART OF THE
STATE AND THE GROWTH OF THE
STATE. AND THE LEADERSHIP THAT
IS OUT THERE I KNOW WE CAN FIND
IT WE JUST NEED TO GET EVERY
EVERYONE INVOLVED AND I
CERTAINLY- ENCOURAGE A PASSING
SENATE BILL SEVEN OLD TOO AND I
WOULD BE- HONORED TO GO HEAD
AND- MAKE THAT MOTION. THANK
YOU SENATOR COME AUGUST. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I TOO WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND WOULD LIKE TO
ASK AT THE APPRPRIATE TIME TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR YOU
KNOW DATA IS IMPORTANT- AND
WHILE WE ARE WORKING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE FILLING SPOTS
ON OUR BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
WITH APPOINTMENTS IT IS ALSO
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE FILLING THEM TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE. DIVERSITY ON THEM
IN A WAY THAT IS REFLECTIVE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND YOU
CANNOT DOTHAT I YOU DON'T
HAVE DATA YOU CANNOT DO THAT IF
YOU'RE NOT REVIEWING THE DATA
AND YOU CAN'T DO THAT IF YOU
ARE NOT YOU KNOW BRINGING FOLKS
TOGETHER IN CONVENING
OPPORTUNITIES TO DISCUSS WHAT
THE OUTCOMES ARE AS IT RELATES
TO THESE APPOINTMENTS AND
COMMISSIONS. SO THAT WE CAN DO
BETTER FOR THE RESIDENTS AND
CONSTITUENTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK THIS IS
WHAT THIS BILL STRIVE TO DO AND
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH OUT OF MY
COLLEAGUES- SENATOR HUESO ABOUT
INCLUDING JUDICIAL COUNCIL I
THINK THAT IS A VERY GOOD IDEA.
ANYBODY ELSE. SO WE HAVE A-
SEVERAL OWN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE PLEASE OR DO WE HAVE IS A
SKEWS ME CENTER LAMONT. WHO'S
WITH YES THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. WILL FIRST OF ALL
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ADD ON TO
EVERYONE'S COMMENTS THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND MORE SPECIFICALLY
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES AS A- RELATES TO THE
DATA. THIS BILL SIMPLY SEEKS TO
REMEDY THE LACK OF DOUBT IN
THIS RESPECT AND TO ENSURE THAT
THE GOAL OF CURRENT LAW WHICH
VERY SPECIFICALLY STATES IT IS
THE POLICY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS. BROADLY REFLECT
THE GENERAL PUBLIC INCLUDING
ETHNIC MINORITIES AND WOMEN. IS
MATT THAT'S ALREADY IN STATE
LAW WE JUST NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THE DATA IS THERE AND THIS FOR
MAKES THE PROPER
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ENSURE THE
DIVERSITY OF THE STATE AND WITH
THAT I ALSO LIKE TO. URGE AN
IDOL THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE.
I'VE GOT GUERRA PURE ON THIS
PLEXIGLASS A WAVE YOUR HAND IF
YOU WANT TO SPEAK PLEASE THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT SO WITH THAT-
SECTOR-LIMóN GOOD BILL. PLEASE
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHEN
MEMBERS AND- I CERTAINLY
WELCOME THAT THE INTEREST IN IN
BECOMING CO AUTHOR AND I
WELCOME MY COLLEAGUES WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS BILL AND ADD TO
MY COLLEAGUE FROM US AND YOU
GUYS POINT WE ABSOLUTELY WILL
LOOK AT JUDICIAL APPOINTMENTS
WE KNOW THE JUDICIAL BRANCH.
HAS A DIVERSITY REPORT AND SO
WE WILL LOOK AT THAT TO SEE IF
IT'S- CONGRUENT WITH WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH AS WELL SO
WEAK THAT I APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I AM. GOOD THANK YOU
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FILE ITEM TWELVE SB SEVEN OH
TWO DOT. BY DOT AYE NIELSEN.
ALLEN HI ALLEN AYE ARE. AYE OR
TO HIGH TECH. BY BAKER I
BORDERS. BRADFORD ALL RIGHT
BRADFORD HI GREG AYE GLAZER
HIGHWAY OF AYE HUESO AYE. JONES
I KAMLAGER I KAMLAGER I'M LINDA.
PORTANTINO RUBIO. RUBIO I WILK.
AND IT'S TEN VOTES FOR THAT
BILL ON. ALL. OKAY. MEMBERS
WERE GOING TO OPEN UP THE ROLE
ON EVERY BILL SO THAT- THOSE
MEMBERS WE GOT A COUPLE MEMBERS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE HERE RIGHT
AWAY BUT I WANT TO GIVE
EVERYBODY HERE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO VOTE AND MOVE ON TO THE REST
OF YOUR DAY. SO WE WILL BEGIN
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE
CRITICAL UNDER. OKAY MEMBERS
THIS IS- ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN HI BRADFORD. ALL RIGHT
BRADFORD AYE JONES. JONES I
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER HI THAT'S.
FIFTEEN ZERO TO FIFTEEN ZERO
THAT BILL IS FILED. GOOD SECOND
ORDERS OUT NOW MOVES TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB THREE EIGHTY
NINE BY SENATOR DODD SECRETARY
PLEASE OPEN THE WRONG ONE SB
THREE EIGHTY NINE THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE SB THREE EIGHTY NINE
BY CHAIRMAN DODD ABSENT MEMBERS
BAKER. BY BAKER HI GORGEOUS.
FOR THREE EIGHTY NINE OR-
BORDERS CREDIT BY FOUR DAYS AYE
BRADFORD ALL RIGHT BRADFORD HI
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER ALL RIGHT
WILK HI WELCOME HI THAT'S
FIFTEEN CHECKS CHECK A SECOND
ZERO SEVEN FIVE ZERO KNOWS THE
BILL'S OUT NOW MOVES TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB FIVE SIXTY
ONE BY DODD SECTOR PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE IN SB FIVE SIXTY ONE
THIS IS FILE ITEM THREE SB FIVE
FIFTY ONE BY GERMAN. DODD
ABSENT MEMBERS SPECTER. HI
BAKER HI PORGES. ALL RIGHT
BORDERS I BRADFORD. FIVE EFFORT
HI KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I WILL HI.
BURKE FIFTEEN ZERO TERM FIFTH
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT NOW MOVES
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S. B.
TWENTY I SAID- CABALLERO PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE ON S. B. TWENTY
EIGHT THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVEN
SB TWENTY EIGHT BY CENTER
CABALLERO ABSENT MEMBERS
BRADFORD. JONES KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER I MELENDEZ. WILK.
THAT'S ELEVEN ZERO CHAIRMAN
ELEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WE
WILL NOW MOVE THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB THREE FOURTEEN
BY CENTER WIENER SECRETARY
PLEASE ROLL THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB THREE FOURTEEN
BY CENTER WINNER ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN. ALLEN HI BAKER HI BAKER
I BRADFORD WORKS FOR IOWA SO.
WHAT UP I KAMLAGER HI CAN I
PORTANTINO. WELL FIVE WELL
CURRENT SEVEN FORTY ZERO ON HOW
MANY FOURTEEN TWO ZERO POINT IT
CHANGES THE BILL'S. STILL ON
CALL YES. NOW MOVES THE FILE
ITEM NUMBER SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE BY SENATOR WIENER SECTOR
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE THIS IS
FILE ITEM NINE SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE BY CENTER WIENER ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN. ALLEN HI BAKER
HI BAKER I BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE HUESO. WEST OF I KAMLAGER
HI CAN AYE PORTANTINO. WILK BYE
BOOK ALL RIGHT FOURTEENS ARE ON
CALL. FOURTEEN ZERO THE BILL'S
ON CALL- WE WILL NOW BE TO FILE
ITEM- TEN BY SENATOR ARCHULETA
YES YOU SEVEN SEVEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THIS IS
FILE ITEM TEN SB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN BY CENTER ARCHULETA
ABSENT MEMBERS SPECTER. BY
BAKER HI KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER
HI MELENDEZ SANTINO WELCOME BYE
WORK I. AT THIRTEEN THIRTY
REMAIN ON CALL THIRTEEN YES
THIRTEEN ZERO LET'S ALL CALL-
JUST BEFORE THE PUBLIC STAKE IN
MEMBERS- I SAID A NUMBER OF
BILLS WERE OUT- WERE HOLDING
THOSE BILLS OPEN FOR CENTER
PORTANTINO I WILL NOW MOVED
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE S. B.
SEVEN OH TWO BY CENTER LOAN
SECTOR PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE HI
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWELVE SB
SEVEN OH TWO BISON EARLY MON.
ABSENT MEMBERS NIELSEN. BORJA
MELENDEZ PORTANTINO WELCOME.
THANK YOU YOU'RE NOT PRESENTING
YOUR. TO EXTENSION TED YEAH GEN
ZERO THAT BILL IS ALL BECAUSE.
WE WILL BE WAITING FOR SAID SIR
PORTANTINO GO BACK THROUGH THE
FILE. ACCORDING ALL HE DID YEAH.
THE GEO COMMITTEE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL. FOR FIVE MINUTES.
OKAY THE GOP WILL GO BACK INTO
SESSION WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT TO OPEN
THE ROLE SB THREE FOURTEEN BY
CENTER WIENER SECTOR OEN THE
ROLE THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHT-
BY CENTER WIENER ABSENT MEMBERS
PORTANTINO. HIGH COURT IN HI
THAT'S DANGEROUS FIFTY ZERO
THAT BILL OUT. THAT WILL MOVE
THE. ALL I NUMBER NINE S. SEVEN
NINETY THREE BUT CENTER WIENER.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE
B. C. NINETY THREE ABSENT PART
IN. HI PORTANTINO HAI FIFTY
ZERO FIFTEEN ZERO THE BILLS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN S. B. TO
SERVE SEVEN BY CENTER. SECTOR
FILE ITEM SB TWO SEVENTY I'M
MEMBERS MAY PORTANTINO. I
PORTANTINO AYE THAT'S FORTY
ZERO FOURTEEN THAT BILL UP ITEM
TWELVE SB SEVEN OH BY SIR LIMA.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TALK SB OH
APPS MEMBERS KNOW. BORDERS
MILAN PORTANTINO. SUGGESTIONS
IN WRITING TO OUR COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
VISUAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS.
IT'S ADJOURNED.